So, jetzt sind wir wieder, ging schneller als gedacht, Passwort am Start, ähm, mal gucken, mal gucken, ob der Stream überhaupt wieder richtig läuft jetzt, weil ich habe jetzt umgestellt, ähm, ich habe jetzt umgestellt auf ein bisschen mehr Bitrate, weil Path of Exile ist halt ziemlich Scroll Intensive und dann Pixels und so, das muss ja nicht sein.
Also, schön, wer noch am Start ist, ich weiß, dass es nicht so wahnsinnig viele interessiert, aber, ähm, ein paar fanden die Streams ja gut und, wie gesagt, ich will mir eh einen neuen Charakter leveln.
Wir fangen an, das ist übrigens mein, mein, mein, nein, ich will nicht mit dem Typ handeln, das ist übrigens mein eigentlicher Farm-Character hier, ähm, wir machen uns jetzt einen neuen.
Ich habe die letzten Leaks immer nur Witch gespielt, in, in paar Varianten, jetzt erstellen wir uns mal einen Stelz-Charakter.
Also, wir, wir machen richtig, es wird, es wird, es wird irgendwie so übelstes Meta-Bild, also irgendeine Mischung, also ich habe mir schon überlegt, wie ich, wie ich level, ich habe mir, ich habe mir angeguckt, was zur Zeit so am schnellsten ist und wahrscheinlich level ich mir ein, ähm, was ist denn das, ein Shadow heißt das, glaube ich, Shadow Trickster mit, ähm, am Anfang ganz normal bis Level 28 irgendwie bis in den Bogen stellst, dann Chaos Spellslinger und am Ende gehe, mache ich dann, ähm, ein, ähm, ein, ähm, ein, ähm, ein, ähm, ein, ähm, ein, ähm, ein, ähm, ein, ähm, ein, ähm, ein, ähm, ein, ähm, ein, ähm, ein, ähm, ein, ähm, ein, ähm, ein, ähm, ein, ähm, ein,
weil ich das schon die ganze Zeit mal spielen wollte, Cock, Eisnova, yep, aber in dem Fall nur COC, ähm, ja, ein bisschen, ein bisschen Gear haben wir am Start, ein bisschen, äh, Currency haben wir am Start, aktuell für neues Gear habe ich 5 Exalted Orbs und 267 Chaos Orbs übrig, also, da sollten wir schon ein bisschen gescheites Gear für bekommen, aber erstmal müssen wir einen neuen Charme machen und den Kram leveln.
Exit, Charakter Selection, so, great, und dann erstmal gucken, dass wir auch den Sound laut genug haben, so, also, okay, was brauchen wir, Shadow, wir brauchen einen Namen, wie sieht es denn aus mit Cute Chat, gibt es den schon, fuck, Cute Chat gibt es schon, okay,
Aiaiaiaia, okay, Aiaiaiaia ist definitiv belegt, das weiß ich jetzt nicht.
Ja, wie sieht es denn mit Aiaiaiaia aus, fuck, Alter, warum ist das alles schon vergeben, Cute Chat, okay, äh, Cute Chat, nee, das hört sich scheiße an, der Name ist, der Name ist im Perspektiv eh vollkommen wurscht, ähm,
Oh, guten Abend, Chat, ansonsten nenne ich den, nenne ich den irgendeine Abwandlung von Poggers oder so, französische Poggers, Poggers, ne, da denken alle ich bin Franzose und wollen ja nicht mit mir traden, ne, Poggers, Poggers FR, ne, das kann man nicht machen,
Oh, fuck, nein, ich will, ich will nicht Poggers FR heißen, noch irgendeinen anderen guten Namen für, ähm, Bashen, Alter, Bashen, okay, Bashen, Alter, heißt er jetzt, okay, exzellent, den Namen gibt es nicht, perfekt, okay, Moment, warte mal kurz, bevor wir anfangen, gucken, dass der Lautstärke stimmt, aber die Gamesound ist ein bisschen leise, ne,
Ich spiele ja immer ohne Gamesound, aber für, für einen Stream kann ich mal ein bisschen lauter machen, Skip allen Tutorials auf jeden Fall, also wie gesagt, ich bin nicht der ultra krasse Speedrunner in dem Game, gar nicht, ne, aber ich hab mir ein paar Sachen abgeguckt jetzt über die letzte Zeit, womit es halbwegs schnell gehen sollte, mal gucken,
Legen wir los, ach Quatsch, man muss den Kram aufheben, ja, stimmt, gucken, ob die Lautstärke okay ist,
Ne, man hört gar nix, oder, ich glaub, man hört gar nix, äh, Master Volume, what the fuck, Master Volume ist voller Wandschlag, lass mal kurz gucken, weil ich, ja, jetzt, jetzt glaub ich, hört man was, wenn ich was kill, die Musik ist etwas zu laut, mal gucken, gucken, wie der Sound ist,
Ich hab, mein Game ist halt null eingestellt auf Sound, ne, übrigens, normalerweise killt man hier gar nix,
Da war die Musik ein T, aber die Musik ist eigentlich okay, ich brauch, ich brauch ein bisschen Musikbeschallung, weil ansonsten krieg ich Anfälle, wenn ich jetzt, äh, 5 Stunden am Stück hier Passive Exile grinde,
Hast du ein Build, ja, oh, Moment, ich muss mal mein Passive Building aufmachen, machen wir gleich in der Stadt, also ich werd bis 28 irgendwie sinnloses Bogenstelz spielen, und dann mach ich 0815 Meter Chaos Belslinger bis, äh, keine Ahnung, 70, 75,
und danach versuch ich mal, bisschen Gear zusammen zu kratzen, für, äh, Kok, Eis-Nova, eigentlich braucht man hier überhaupt nix killen, ich mein, genug Currency hab ich am Start, um zumindest ein Budget-Build zusammen zuahlen,
also das wird jetzt, äh, ich weiß nicht, ob man mal in der Stadt so ein...
Also was heißt Budget, wenn ne Reddit glaubst, ist ja jedes Build, was mehr als, äh, 20 Chaos kostet, äh, Useless, aber Reddit is halt Reddit, ne, und das sagt ja nix, also was macht人, ist mir nix,, ich will jetzt eigentlich Ravenouth怎isten saving, aber Red DOUBT ist durchaus keine Möglichkeit, ведь...
Ich als relativer Noob in dem Game.
Aber Reddit schreibt dann auch viel Bullshit,
wenn der Tag lang ist.
Äh, hab ich
meinen Skill nicht aufgehoben? Kann das sein?
Ich hab meinen Skill nicht aufgehoben.
WTF, ey. Ich kank nur,
ich hab meinen Skill nicht aufgehoben. Stell dir das mal vor.
Aber ich brauch den Skill eh nicht.
Das gibt's nicht. Ich hab vergessen, meinen Skill aufzunehmen.
Geht schon richtig gut los, ey.
Brauch Leben. Leute.
Wir fahrt.
Kek W.
Ha, guck mal, jetzt trägt 17 hier.
Oh, ne. Scheiße.
Wo hab ich meinen Skill?
Ah, ich hab den Loot-Filter
drin. Ich hab den fucking Loot...
Jetzt weiß ich, warum ich da nix seh.
Ich muss den Loot-Filter noch rausnehmen.
Rennt der einem ewig nach?
Guckt euch mal an, ey.
Ah. Easy.
Wir machen das Ganze jetzt einfach nochmal.
Ich muss
den Loot-Filter ändern.
Ich glaub, ich seh nix hier drin. Ja, da hab ich nicht
aufgenommen. Doch, ich seh was. Was hab ich für einen Loot-Filter
da drinne?
Strict? Ne, Strict ist eigentlich okay.
Strict ist gut für neuen Char.
Oder Strix?
Tobix! 9919, dankeschön.
Ich muss jetzt erstmal
die Gegner killen hier.
Und vielleicht sollte ich den Kram
auch mal sockeln.
Kann das sein, dass man null Life-Rack hat?
Man hat null
Life-Rack, Alter.
So, jetzt aber.
Lol. Wie schlecht.
Alter, wie schlecht.
Ja, zumindest, äh, ich muss
mir gleich noch das Pass-off-Building raussuchen.
Was ich brauche
für...
Weil aus dem Kopf weiß ich's nicht.
Ich weiß noch so ungefähr, wo man lang muss.
Man nimmt sich hier die Chaos-Nodes.
Geht man irgendwie hier nochmal kurz hoch, dann...
Mal gucken, mal gucken, wie weit
ich ohne Pass-off-Building komm.
Excellent Speedrun.
Perfekt, ja.
Das Game sieht überraschend gut aus.
Findste?
Alter.
WTF? Ich hab noch nicht mal das Ding aufgenommen.
Ich bin noch nie, noch nie
verreckt, Alter. Noch nie.
Ey, dieses Scheiß-Gewinn gibt's zwar nicht.
Ey, wie schlecht.
Das Game sieht, äh,
auch nur auf den ersten Blick gut aus. Das hat
ziemlich, äh,
ähm,
Probleme.
Wenn mehr Gegner auf dem Bildschirm sind.
Kann man weiter rauszoomen?
Nee, nee, nee, das war's.
Weiter rauszoomen kann man nicht.
Alter, World First Hiloq, der ist...
So, jetzt aber.
Guck mal, dafür sind wir schon Level 1.
Aber ich glaub, wir sind immer Level 1.
Äh, wird Pass of Exile dann nur
ein Update oder ein neues Spiel?
Angeblich,
angeblich neue Engine.
Oder großes Engine-Upgrade.
Aber
nachdem Endgame und sowas alles
behalten wird, beibehalten wird,
ähm,
äh, ist es wahrscheinlich,
eher ein größeres Upgrade.
Zepter brauchen wir nicht.
Die ganzen Crap-Sellen.
So, also, ich hab, äh,
Level Equip auf einem anderen Char.
Allerdings,
mal gucken, wie gut wir hier vorankommen ohne Level Equip.
Mal schauen.
So, also, was wir brauchen
ist, wenn ich das richtig sehe,
wir brauchen jetzt erstmal...
Ist hier irgendwie was? Nee.
Brauchen wir alles nicht.
Im Zweifelsfall, falls wir gar nichts finden.
So, wir brauchen jetzt erstmal...
Wir brauchen erst einmal
ein paar Gems.
Genau, also, wir haben das hier,
Lesser Poison, wir brauchen irgendwas
Dings, Arrow, wie heißt das? Caustic Arrow
brauchen wir. Äh,
und Pierce.
Aber Pierce gibt's noch nicht, ne?
Pierce gibt's noch nicht. Pierce gibt's erst
später. Ich glaub, Pierce gibt's beim, bei
Mercy Mission dann.
So, dann mal schauen, ob der irgendwie einen Bogen hat, der Dude.
Irgendeinen Bogen haben
die nix gesch... Also, das ist ja Crap, äh...
Sucked.
Irgendwas...
Irgendwas mit zwei... Jetzt willst du
irgendwas finden mit zwei, äh, Sachen
drin, äh. Was für ein Bild?
Also, ich will später, will ich Cast
on Crit, äh, Eisnurfer mal
ausprobieren. Das wollte ich schon letzte League ausprobieren,
aber hab's voll verkackt.
Äh, leveln werd ich komplett, übrigens,
wenn man mal seine Spells richtig legen
würde. Äh,
leveln werd ich
mit...
8 bis 28
hier mit, äh, Bogenstelz und
danach Spellslinger, Chaos, Chaos
Spellslinger.
So richtig, richtig Meta-Slave-mäßig.
Kauf dir...
Ich hab nen Tabula auf'm anderen Char.
Ich hab alles am Start
zum leveln.
Ich hab nen Tabula am Start,
ich hab nen Goldrim am Start, ich hab, äh,
Movement Boots am Start.
Ich hab alles am Start.
Müsst du doch rübermulen
vom anderen Char.
Eine nice Vorbereitung, ja.
So,
wir brauchen Bogen, wir brauchen Bogen mit, ähm,
grünen Sockel.
By the way, ich weiß,
die krassen Speedrunners, die machen das nicht.
Die krassen Speedrunners, die rennen durch.
Wir machen jetzt, passt mal auf, Leute, wir machen jetzt
huge, wir machen jetzt huge
Speedrun-Stats machen wir jetzt.
Nachdem wir hier fertig sind.
Huge, huge Speedrun-Stats, passt auf.
Hab ich mir, hab ich mir abgeguckt.
Massive Speedrun-Stats.
Aber dazu bräuchte man nen gescheiten Bogen.
Wir gehen jetzt nämlich nicht zur Mercy-Mission,
wie, wie das alle Noobs machen, also
inklusive mir, ähm,
sondern, wir gehen jetzt direkt zurück,
ähm, machen die
Eggs, und
gehen dann zurück, gehen dann
in die Submerged Passage,
und von dort, dem Waypoint,
gehen wir zurück und machen Mercy-Mission.
Massive
Speedrun-Stats.
Excellent.
Pfeifert, ja.
Ich hab übrigens noch in
irgendeiner Kiste auch noch einen 3-Link-Bogen
reingelegt, ne?
Ne, da geht's noch nicht lang.
Ich muss erst mal die Eier finden.
Wo sind die Eier?
So, und wenn wir als nächstes in die Stadt gehen,
muss ich mir das Pass of Building aufmachen,
da ich richtig skille.
Ah, da sind die Eier.
Ah, ja, ja.
Könnte mal irgendwie nen Bogen droppen,
der mehr als einen grünen Sockel hat?
Ja, arm.
So, und jetzt, jetzt kommen die,
die Hyper-Speedrun-Stats.
Jetzt geht man nämlich hier oben lang.
Scheiß drauf, da geht doch ein blaues
Pack, können wir killen, blaue Packs bringen,
fett XP.
Auf, umkippen.
So, und jetzt gehen wir nämlich hier oben rein,
gehen in die
Submerged Passage rein, gehen in den
Waypoint und gehen zurück und machen die Quest.
Big Brain.
Speedrun-Stats.
Ich hab mir auch für mich mal so grob
aufgeschrieben, in welcher Reihenfolge man was machen muss.
Das hab ich auf dem zweiten Monitor auf, aber
hab nicht einmal drauf geguckt.
So, und jetzt gehen wir zurück an die Coast
und jetzt haben wir irgendwie zwei Minuten gespart.
Jetzt machen wir die Quest.
Und jetzt specken wir
Dings hier erstmal. Bin mir ziemlich sicher,
dass ich hier oben lang muss.
Chaos Damage, Chaos Damage.
Ja.
Irgendwie sind die Maps grad alle von rechts nach links.
Was?
Arabische Maps heute.
Ich brauch nen Bogen
mit zwei grünen Sockeln spielen,
da kann doch nicht zu viel verlangt sein.
Anscheinend schon.
Nicht erlaubt.
Gleich noch mal beim Händler gucken.
Übrigens, die Händler,
die wechseln ihr Inventar
nicht nach Zeit, sondern
nach Level-Up. Das heißt, wenn man sich wundert,
warum die Händler immer den gleichen Grams haben,
dann liegt das daran,
weil man auch kein Level-Up hatte. Das hab ich am Anfang
auch nicht gecheckt.
Wo ist denn der Dude hier?
Der Boss,
der Bossmann.
Hab ich den Bossmann übersehen?
Der Bossmann ist doch normalerweise immer hier.
Irgendwo unten, oder?
Wo ist der Bossmann?
User32DLL, ich hab doch vorher
zwei, drei Stunden gestreamt schon.
Und ich hab gefragt, ob ihr
gucken wollt?
Und es haben viele
gesagt, ja. Ne, der Bossmann ist da nicht.
Ich dachte, der Bossmann ist immer unten rechts.
Ah, hier, jetzt kommt der
Bossmann. Irgendwo hier.
Ah.
Live Flask. So, Bossmann.
Zack.
Die sind halt am Anfang, die halten halt echt
nix aus.
Mana, Mana, Medicine Chest.
So, äh, Live Flask,
zack, Mana Flask.
So.
Äh, und jetzt ist glaube ich
der Speed-Rantrick, man geht zur Character Selection
und geht wieder rein,
dass man in der Stadt landet.
Ah, excellent.
Massive,
Big Brain. So.
Okay, ähm, jetzt holt man sich hier
den ganzen Krempel ab.
Quicksilver für Speed, was gibt's hier?
Pierce Support.
Exakt, das brauchen wir.
Und ein Skill-Buch gibt's glaube ich auch.
Nee. Irgendein Crap,
was wir nicht brauchen.
Kann man sich für später schon mal holen.
Wie viele Stunden hast du
insgesamt? Äh, keine Ahnung.
Ich hab jetzt ja ne ganze Weile nicht
gespielt, bis, äh,
nur vor vorletzten Season.
Also ein Account, der ist in der Beta erstellt worden.
In der Beta, äh, 2013
oder so. So, also das Game
möchte mir keinen ordentlichen Bogen geben.
Moment, Bogen geht's bei dem anderen
Dude. Da muss ich mal in meine Kiste
gucken, da hab ich nämlich irgendwo noch was.
So, Bogen. Ah, guck mal!
Excellent.
26 Decks.
Zack.
Perfekt. Wie viele Decks fehlen mir noch? 23.
Ist jetzt euer Ernst? Okay, da muss ich noch ein Level
in diesem Crap-Ding hier spielen, auch okay.
Aber ich hab schon einige Stunden, also
keine Ahnung, fünf, äh,
ich weiß es nicht, aber
ordentlich, ordentlich.
Aber auch, aber auch nicht mehr so viel, wie ich
früher gecrindet hab. Ich hab ja früher teilweise MMOs
in 10 Stunden am Tag gecrindet.
Äh, jetzt mach ich das vielleicht ein Tag die Woche, 10 Stunden
äh, crinden. Ansonsten nur,
nur weniger, ja.
Ah, ich hab übrigens was vergessen.
Man sieht, dass ich nicht der krasse Speedrunner bin.
Ich brauch ja noch mal
ein Movement Skill.
Ich brauch ja noch eine Runde Frostblink.
Purchase.
Frost.
Frost, Frost, Frost,
Frostblink.
Excellent.
So, jetzt haben wir nämlich hier alles drin. Wir haben
Pierce Support, äh, Poison Support.
So, wir brauchen
bloß noch ein Level-Up für Decks.
Das halten wir aus damit.
Ich hab gedacht, du hättest nach dem Fail von Overwatch
eine ganze Zeit lang gar kein Spiel... Ja, hab ich auch.
Also, ich hab wenig gespielt. Ich hab, wie gesagt,
ich spiel ja auch erst seit,
seit Metamorph wieder aktiv hier.
Ich hab davor relativ viel gespielt
und wie gesagt, der Account ist von der Beta.
Sterben.
Boss. Fisch.
Alter, ungelinkt sind die Games so schlecht.
Vielleicht haben wir,
vielleicht haben wir Glück, vielleicht haben wir Glück.
Nein, haben wir nicht.
Kann ich nicht mal anziehen.
Aber nach Overwatch stimmt, nach Overwatch
hab ich wirklich nicht viel gespielt.
So, jetzt haben wir wenigstens ein bisschen Speed. Äh, und Frostblink.
Tja, Frostblink, Frostblink
können wir da wenigstens hier reinmachen.
Ne, das ist das falsche. Äh, Moment.
Frostblink. Frostblink.
So.
Frostblink.
Ah, so, jetzt haben wir ein bisschen Movement Speed.
Sonst kriegst du ja den kompletten Anfall hier.
Oh, mein, mein
Mapping ist nicht drauf. Auf der Maus seh ich grad.
Ich hab normalerweise
die Flasche auf der Maus,
dass es schneller geht.
So, ich hoffe, kann ich jetzt den gescheiten Bogen
nehmen? Immer noch nicht.
Ich muss meine Maus richtig legen.
Weil ansonsten hier ohne Speed
kriegst du ja am Rad.
So, Trick 17 ist jetzt, man sucht
Ledge. Das hab ich mir auch bei
SpeedrunnerDude abgeguckt.
Trick 17 ist jetzt, man sucht Ledge
und geht dann da raus?
Je nachdem,
was man zuerst findet.
Ob man zuerst den
findet, wo es runter geht, oder zuerst Ledge
findet.
Passt auf, Leute, nächstes Jahr
Pass of Exile World Record.
Genau, und jetzt
geht man durch bis zum Waypoint.
Grab den Waypoint
und geht schnell wieder zurück.
Soweit von der Theorie her.
Und ich muss meine Maus belegen,
weil ansonsten
krieg ich Anfälle, wenn ich immer
das Ding drücken muss.
Immer meine Flask
drücken muss.
1ks, die machen zu viel Damage.
Ja, aber Overwatch
war schon ein harter Fail.
Overwatch
Ich finde,
Overwatch hatte so viel Potential,
ne? An sich
als Game. Und Overwatch
war auch richtig gut gemacht.
Aber das Handling von Blizzard,
wie sie dann im Endeffekt auch
versucht haben, das Meta in dem
Spiel zu beeinflussen und so.
Oh, also
also viel Spaß
hatte ich da nicht mehr dran.
Skillen wir jetzt einfach mal.
Und dann kann ich nämlich den Bogen nehmen
und endlich mal gescheite Gems reinmachen.
So, und bei der Gelegenheit
gehen wir mal bei der Maus rein und stellen
Maus auf 5.
Äh, Maus? Wo ist meine Maus?
Das da.
Moment, wie ging das nochmal?
Wie konnte man den Kram nochmal belegen?
Tasten.
Tastendruck.
Nee.
Fail zuweisen.
Tastendruck 4.
Das hier 5.
Weil dann
kann man nämlich
einfach das mit der Maus
zünden. Das ist viel einfacher.
Äh, du hast Overwatch
deinstalliert, der kann nicht verstehen.
Jetzt machen wir wenigstens ein bisschen Damage.
Jetzt ist es nicht hier so rumgegräbselt mehr.
So, jetzt kann ich mit der Maus auch meine Flasks hinziehen.
Ja, jetzt geht das doch schon ein bisschen
deutlich angenehmer.
Bisschen Speed hier.
Jetzt müssen wir die komische Krabbe killen.
Wir haben einen Bash.
Wenn euch das interessiert, ihr müsst euch mal
unbedingt
mal einen guten Speedrun hier angucken.
Von quasi 0 auf
Kampagne durch.
Die Leute sind echt
übertrieben krass. Vor allem, wie gut die erkennen,
wie die Maps aufgebaut sind. Ich weiß nicht,
wie die das machen.
Du hast da teilweise, die jumpen hier übelst
rum und wissen, ah, ich muss
jetzt nach rechts unten, weil sie irgendwie einen Felsen
gesehen haben. Der Shep steht und hat das Felsen
der Shep steht, erkennt man,
wo es weitergeht. Total abgedreht.
Also da gibt es schon richtige Pros.
Probies.
Da ist das Viech.
Der Dweller.
Hat sich ausgeduellt.
So, das macht gleich ein bisschen mehr Damage.
Wenn man das richtige Zeug hat.
Sonst können wir alles sellen gleich.
Alles sellen.
So, und jetzt ist glaube ich die Speedruns Threat.
Man geht in Character Selection.
Geht wieder rein.
Und dann geht man zurück Ledge und macht
Ledge fertig. Aber vorher verkaufe ich
mein Kram.
Oh ne, jetzt nicht.
Habe ich keinen Bock krasse Trading
Action zu machen.
So, und jetzt, wenn ich Glück habe, war ich
schnell genug und die Ledge ist wieder neu
geladen. Nicht neu geladen. Perfekt.
So.
Wenn ich hier durch bin, muss ich echt mal mein Pass of Building
aufmachen, weil sonst verskill ich mich.
Hey, wir machen auf einmal Damage.
Sachen gibts.
Gehts ab.
Jetzt kommt dieses komische Viech hier.
Ich glaube den muss man gar nicht killen, ne?
Ich glaube die ganzen
Speedrun Dudes rennen da immer dran vorbei.
Zumindest kann er nix.
Also ich werde mein Levelgear rübermulen.
Weil ich wollte eigentlich mal gucken,
wie schnell es klappt ohne.
Das ist relativ
easy am Anfang noch. Wir müssen jetzt einfach
immer weiter bis wir ins Prison kommen.
Oh, da unten spackt die Grafik aber.
Weil kommt jetzt nicht erstens mit den
Schiffen noch?
Ne, das kommt später.
Wir müssen jetzt hier direkt durch.
Wollen wir ein KS?
Die Radtypen machen übelst
Damage. Perfekt.
Leute, was gab es bei euch
zum Essen abends?
Ich dachte, ich muss mich
ja anstatt mit Barbecue Pit Boys
musste ich mich ja mit
Toastbrot zufrieden geben.
Ich glaube den Dude muss man auch nicht
killen.
Ich glaube das ist alles nur
gebatet. Schaschlik. Geht nicht schlecht.
Nur Müll.
So.
Und jetzt muss ich mein Pass of Building aufmachen.
Weil sonst habe ich keine Ahnung.
Ist das schon der Fork oder ist das?
Woran erkennt man,
ob das der Fork ist?
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob ich hier die richtige Version drauf habe.
Ah, das ist der Community Fork. Excellent.
So, ähm.
Wir brauchen irgendein Bild.
Irgendein Pass of Building.
Krillax, dankeschön.
Acht Monate. Excellent.
Dankeschön für den Sub.
Hat der ein Pass of Building Link drinne?
Gut. Nehmen wir das.
Import.
Okay.
Ich bin begeistert. Ich habe es geschafft
bei den ersten 5 Leveln mich nicht zu verskillen.
Chaos Damage, Chaos Damage.
Okay, wir machen erstmal Chaos Damage.
Erstmal Damage
und dann ein bisschen Life und
Leech. Ja, so machen wir das.
Nur da ich so ungefähr grob durchblick, was Sache ist.
Jetzt haben wir hier
Added Lightning. Brauchen wir nicht.
Brauchen wir nicht.
Das können wir mitnehmen. Das brauchen wir später.
Irgendwas zum Anziehen.
Gürtel oder so, was gescheites.
Top.
Ich habe hier aber noch
Zeugs in der Kiste.
Seeds.
Meine Kiste ist
äußerst aufgeräumt, wie ihr seht.
Das ist noch vom Leveln hier.
Da hätte ich auch noch einen Bogen drin.
Irgendwie billig Gürtel oder so.
Guck mal, ich hätte sogar noch einen
3 Link Bogen gehabt, Low Level.
Also hier blickt man doch
voll durch in der Kiste, oder?
Brauchen wir jetzt eh nicht.
Ich will schon, dass man da gut durchblickt.
So, also was skillen wir jetzt?
Damage, haben wir gesagt.
Damage erstmal hier runter.
Und dann hier rauf.
Chaos Damage.
Excellent.
So.
Kist FPS, genau.
Haben wir schon Ringe?
Sackt aber, das brauchen wir nicht.
Wir brauchen ordentliche Sachen.
Levelst du?
Ich levele jetzt erstmal bis 28.
Hier mit diesen Bogenstellens weiter.
Und dann mache ich
Chaos Spellslinger
bis 70, 75
und dann wollte ich mir ein bisschen
Gear kaufen für
Cast on Grid
Ice Nova.
Habe ich letztens
ein richtig nices Build Showcase gesehen.
Das wollte ich auch mal ausprobieren.
Wollte ich letzte League schon ausprobieren, bin ich dazu gekommen.
Ich habe ein bisschen Budget übrig.
Also ich krieg's, ich krieg da
zumindest ein halbwegs Budget
Bild krieg ich zusammen.
Ich habe 5 Exols und glaube ich 270 Chaos Orbs übrig.
Da krieg ich schon halbwegs was
zusammen.
Genau, was ich am Anfang gesagt habe.
Wenn's nach Reddit geht,
und wie gesagt, ich bin ja immer noch ziemlicher Noob in dem Game,
weil ich EW nicht gespielt habe.
Wenn's nach Reddit geht, ist jedes Build,
jeder Build Guide, der mehr als, keine Ahnung,
20 Chaos kostet, Crap.
Was aber schwachsinnig ist,
weil die richtig guten Sachen kosten halt einfach ein bisschen was.
Und auch diese
Einsteiger Guides, wenn man damit später
also quasi
High End Maps machen will.
Fuck, wo geht's denn hier lang?
Und das
halbwegs schnell, dann braucht man da auch
ein bisschen Investment.
Also mit irgendwie
hier mit 20
Chaos Orbs kommst du nicht weit.
Außer vielleicht als noch
die ganzen
Summoner Dinger komplett unnerved waren,
da konntest du wirklich mit fast nichts
und Skeletten und sowas
zum Beispiel fast alles farmen.
Das war OP.
As fuck.
Hast du die Season auch schon gespielt?
Okay.
Ist super teuer.
Also ich hab mal geguckt, heut Morgen,
so der Spur nach,
also die
Rüstung wird wohl das teuerste werden.
Ah.
Fuck, wo ist das Ding hier?
Die Rüstung wird wohl das teuerste werden.
Aber ich hoff mal, dass ich so mit
3-4 Exalts hinkomm, dass es
gut spielbar ist. Da ist natürlich keine
super High-End-Chest mit
Explosive und Gedöns drin.
Nee,
ich würde gerne mit Explosive-Chest spielen,
die Sache ist, bloß die, entweder muss ich
die selber craften und mir geht das Harvest-Craften
mega auf den Sack, also ich bin keiner, der gerne Harvest
craftet.
Oder
ich kauf mir halt irgendeine billige
Explody-Chest.
Oder lass es
ganz bleiben.
Wichtiger ist, dass ich
Reflect-Immun
auf meiner Chest hab,
dass ich mehr Maps machen kann.
Haben wir irgendwas
geschafft? Ah, das ist gut.
Das brauchen wir später.
Also, mein Main,
leider kann ich die
Chest von meinem Main
nicht verwenden.
Main hab ich angefangen als
ähm, äh
Dings, wie heißt's nochmal?
Äh, Dings hier, äh,
wie heißt, wie heißt denn das Spell nochmal?
Das zum Indie, das, äh,
wo du
Gegner in die Luft sprengst und
Feuerbälle rauskommen.
Volatile Dead und, und, äh,
Fuck, keine Ahnung.
Ich komm grad nicht drauf,
wie das Spell heißt.
Ähm, da hab ich
ne ganz gute, Moment,
was, wo lauf ich denn hier gerade rum?
Da hab ich ne ganz gute
Chest,
aber die kann ich nicht, genau, Spells,
Spellslinger, Volatile Dead und, und
Corpse Explosion oder, ich weiß nicht, wie das Spell genau
heißt. Mit, äh,
Impulsa und, äh,
also Impulsa, Sixth Link und
relativ gutes Gear. Natürlich bei weitem nicht
so das, was da manche Leute hier im Stream am Start haben.
Und das geht halt durch wie nix,
ja, machst du T16 Maps und, und
lullst dir einen ab dabei.
Außer Bosse, für Bosse ist es nicht
so gut.
Warum lauf ich so dumm, ey? Ich hab die
Kampagne schon 30 Mal gespielt gefühlt, aber, äh,
ich weiß eigentlich, wo es lang geht, aber
wenn ich, wenn ich Chat gucken muss, ist
irgendwie, Braindead.
Kennst du von
früher noch Wahl, Fireball? Ne,
das war die Zeit, wo ich nicht gespielt hab.
Das war
die Zeit, da hab ich nicht gespielt.
Also, ich hab, ich hab, wie gesagt,
ich hab die Beta gespielt, ziemlich
viel danach, ein bisschen, aber da gab's
das ganze Wahlzeugs noch gar nicht.
Die Kampagne ging auch, glaube ich,
gerade mal bis zu Dominus.
Mensch, mach mal kurz ein Portal,
dass der Typ mich nicht ownt.
Ey, gehst du fort?
Pepo, fett.
Ja, mach mal.
Mach da mal weiter.
Au.
Oh, jetzt will er's wissen.
Jetzt will er's wissen.
Müsste ein Stead sein.
Stead.
Sterben, please.
Big. Sick.
Heißt das. Nicht big.
Ey, also, wie gesagt, das Wahlzeugs gab's
damals noch nicht. Und als so richtig, wirklich
angefangen hab ich auch erst wieder, als
Metamorph rausgekommen ist. Da war's mir
ultra langweilig und ich hab mir gedacht, Alter, du hast schon
lang kein Path of Exile mehr gespielt.
Als ich mit Metamorph angefangen hab, hab ich dann gar
nicht mehr aufgehört.
Alter, was? Crap.
Okay, ich mul mir gleich echt mal
Level Gear rüber.
Ich wollte eigentlich mal gucken, wie gut man hier durchkommt
ohne Level Gear, aber ey, das ist ja
mühselig as fuck.
Ach, Quatsch, das geht ja gar nicht lang.
Wow.
Bisschen leveln muss ich, bin ziemlich, relativ low.
Aber ich glaube,
es ist ein ganz guter Indikator dafür, wenn man
ein Ticken über dem Level
der Zone ist.
Wow. Den G-Baiten wir jetzt, guck mal.
Kack.
Kack-Noob-Gegner.
Oder auch nicht.
Steigt nicht drauf ein.
Irgendwas mit Movement Speed?
Auch
Müll.
Eigentlich, wenn ich richtig pro wäre, was ich natürlich
nicht bin, würde ich jetzt schon nebenbei
nach Gear gucken.
Aber ich brauch eh...
Also, ich hab
letztens ein Video gesehen,
Speedrun in, glaub,
dreieinhalb Stunden oder so, bis
Kampagne durch, aber der Typ ist
ultrakrass, ey.
Musst ihr mal racen.
Den kenn ich, den kenn ich.
Ja, das ist auch krass. Also, in dem Run
war, glaub, TaiTaiKiller, den ich mir angeguckt
hab. Ähm...
Aber andere sind auch geil.
Aber hier, das, ey, also, dreieinhalb Stunden
ist echt übertrieben heftig.
Guck mal, hier muss ich nicht lang, oder?
Glaub, ich muss runter.
Aber dreieinhalb Stunden für die
Kampagne ist schon heftig. Und der macht das
ohne Gear, muss man sagen, ne?
Also, der fängt komplett bei null an
und, und nur mit Loot.
In dreieinhalb Stunden.
Voll heftig, ey.
Ich brauch wahrscheinlich sieben
Stunden oder so.
Haben wir schon.
Mal kurz gucken. Gibt's denn hier...
Mana Gain on Kill
ist schon mal sehr gut.
Mana Gain on Kill.
Und haben wir, haben wir irgendwo Leech?
Ah! Attack Damage Leech
das Life. Excellent. Ok, perfekt.
Dann gehen wir erstmal hier hoch.
Gehen wir erstmal hier hoch.
Increase Damage. Life.
Mana.
Oder nee, nee, wir holen jetzt erstmal
Life Leech. Ich kann ruhig Mana Flask drücken.
Das juckt mich nicht.
Normale Spieler brauchen im
Schnitt ne Stunde pro Akt.
Ja.
Also Akt 1 und 2,
ich weiß, es wirkt jetzt zwar nicht so,
aber wenn ich für mich hier sitze und
auf Chat guck, Akt 1, 2,
inklusive 3 eigentlich auch, kann ich
mehr oder weniger auswendig.
Muss ich dann mal großartig gucken.
Ich hab mir auch schon mal so nen Miniguide
für mich selbst geschrieben, wo einfach die wichtigsten
Steps drinne stehen.
Hier muss man jetzt das Schiff suchen.
Das Schiff suchen.
Das Slave
Grill
finden.
Ah, guck mal, da geht's schon hier. Da sind wir doch schon.
Das war gut hier.
Dass wir das direkt gefunden haben.
Direkt hier rein.
Slave Grill.
Aufheben und dann Fair Graves.
Also ich denk mal, Akt 1 und 2
und 3 bin ich halbwegs
schnell mittlerweile, weil ich den Kram
ganz gut auswendig kenn.
Danach muss ich ein bisschen mehr
in meinen Guide gucken.
Aber was bei den Speedrunnern halt übelst geil ist,
wie gut die die Map erkennen.
Und
die erklären ja manchmal auch im Stream
so ein bisschen auf was sie gucken.
Das ist echt abgedreht.
Die erzählen dir dann so Sachen wie,
wir sehen, der Felsen,
der ist jetzt hier ein bisschen in den einen Felsen
reingeclitscht und daran erkenne ich,
dass der Boss oben links ist.
Was? Aha, alles klar.
Ich hätte noch nicht mal den Felsen erkannt.
Guck her, komplett falsch gerannt.
Ja, oder andere
Sachen, dass sie dann sagen, ja,
da ist irgend so ein Graffiti auf der Wand
und daran erkenne ich, die Map geht jetzt
eher tendierte Richtung rechts.
Oder in die linke Richtung.
Jetzt, wo das Spawnen
vom Boss ist und so. Übelst geil.
Keine Ahnung, wie die... Wow, wow, wow, wow, wow.
Ist ja gut hier.
Ja, ja, ist gut, Boss.
Ist gut.
Ich habe halt übelst Crap an.
Ich meine, ich könnte
Brassplate anziehen,
aber das macht mich so langsam.
Moment.
Lebt der wieder? Ach, das ist der andere
Dude. Oh.
Exzellent.
Lightning Resistance.
Brauche ich die Cold Resistance für den Bossfight
gleich?
Hier, alle mal besser als den Mist, den ich habe.
Alles besser als
den Mist, den ich habe.
Strength, Maximum Life, Mana
Regeneration. Komm, gib mir ein bisschen
Movement Speed, please.
Bless RNG, wobei, Bless RNG gibt es ja nicht mehr.
Ah, kein Movement Speed.
Ein bisschen Life, okay.
Komm, alles sellen
gleich.
Was hat man gesagt? Den da?
Ah, Life Gain und Kill. Echt? Dann haben wir
ja beides, wenn wir hier hochgehen und das
Skin haben wir. Mana und Life Frag. Ja, das ist
schön. Das finde ich gut.
So, machen wir das.
So.
Wo steckt Fair Graves jetzt?
Eigentlich
kann man auf der Web gar nicht viel falsch laufen, weil
entweder findet man den Ausgang, wo man später
lang muss, oder man findet Fair Graves.
Kann die Quest abgeben, da unten
ist er.
Kann da eigentlich nicht viel schief gehen.
Ich finde die
späteren... Moment.
Geht's hier lang?
Die späteren Akte ziehen sich immer so.
Ich finde auch, dass die ersten
vier, fünf Acts
sind irgendwie mit mehr Liebe gemacht,
habe ich so den Eindruck, ja. Also,
der Rest
wirkt halt auch teilweise
extrem recycelt. Immer die
gleichen Bosse. Ich meine,
die,
diese drei Hauptgegner,
die es da in der Kampagne gibt, die kommen ja dreimal.
Dreimal recycelt.
Einmal normal, dann nochmal
und zum Schluss nochmal so als Abbilder.
Da haben sie es echt
übertrieben.
Mit Recycling.
So, jetzt müssen wir nur noch den Ausgang finden.
Ah, guck mal,
da ist er.
Au,
das wird schwierig. Ich bräuchte, ich bräuchte echt
ein bisschen Kälteres.
Ohne Kälteres ist wirklich
Crap.
Ja.
Ich gehe mal in die Stadt, mein Skillbuch abholen.
Das ist übrigens
eine Sache, wo die ganzen Speedrunner
ultra Zeit sparen im Vergleich zu so Casual Noobs.
Die gehen irgendwie nur zweimal in die Stadt pro
Akt. Also nur, wenn es sein muss.
Flamedash.
Auch mal Flame. Ich muss mal kurz gucken. Flamedash.
Ja. Flamedash.
Flamedash.
Zu wenig
Int. Stellt euch das mal vor.
Ah. Viel Int brauche ich noch.
33. Ja, Wahnsinn.
Okay, haben wir, haben wir gleich.
Kann ich, kann ich gleich specken.
35.
Ja, richtig Three Head, Alter.
Brauche ich für später
hier irgendwas? Ne, ne.
Essence Train kann ich schon mal mitnehmen.
Essence Train brauchen wir später.
Ne, also, jetzt bin ich eigentlich
richtig
erstmal die ganzen Mist hier sellen.
Besser ordnen,
sonst sell ich noch Zeugs, was
ich nicht sellen will.
Finde ich da jetzt nicht drauf an.
So, ich, ich mull mir mal mein Levelgear schnell
rüber.
Wo ist denn hier mein letzten
Char?
Ich hab da irgendeinen 70er Stelser.
Der müsste noch Levelgear
haben.
Der müsste noch Levelgear am Start haben.
Exzellent.
Guck mal da, der hat alles, was man,
alles was wir brauchen hat er noch.
Perfekt.
Na dann,
da kann nichts mehr schief gehen.
Äh,
wo ist mein Char? Ah,
bashen, Alter.
Brauchen wir später noch, weil der hat ähnliche Skills
wie die, die ich brauche. Ah, ne, die sind zu weit aufgelevelt.
So,
jetzt erstmal ein gescheites Levelgear anziehen.
Zack Resis, Zack Runspeed,
Zack, äh,
Skills.
Wenn ich da mal Skills brauche.
Sehr gut.
So, jetzt brauche ich ein bisschen Int.
Muss irgendwo ein bisschen Int herkriegen.
Dann halt nicht. Dann skillen wir erstmal hier weiter.
Ah, hier. Achso, Int.
Perfekt. So, zack.
Flamedash.
Äh, wo bekommt man denn so eine?
Einfach traden.
Ist am Ende der League sogar relativ
günstig. Letzte League habe
ich zwei Stück selbst gefunden, total random.
Also,
entweder du lässt dir vom Nick so eine geben,
ähm, aber das einfachste
ist zu traden, wenn du in der Trade League, äh,
Trade League bist.
Ähm, die richtigen
Pros erfarmen die sich denn am Anfang von
der League. Du kannst in
Blood Aqueducts, das ist Act 9,
in Act 9
kannst du das innerhalb ein paar Stunden erfarmen.
Ja, 10,
13, das ist ein G-Bait Angebot.
13, 14 Chaos.
Also, zum Level lohnt
sich's wirklich. Wobei man sagen muss, ähm,
bei dem Build, was ich jetzt hier eigentlich spielen
will, ist das gar nicht so, gar nicht so
wichtig, weil,
ich komm auch mit 4 Links, mit, mit
4 Links aus. Allerdings,
der Vorteil ist, ich
brauch halt keine Links suchen
im Endeffekt. Kann's einfach reinsockeln und gut ist.
Ups.
Lame Dash.
Übrigens, als Trade
Seite wird's immer
die Offizielle nehmen. Früher hat man Links hier
genommen, ähm, PoE
Trade. Aber
die Offizielle Trade Seite ist
mittlerweile eigentlich das Beste.
Was für ein Build machen
hast du? Wie gesagt, ich level jetzt erst
mal hier Bogenstelz bis 28,
da mach ich Chaos-Belslinger
bis 70 und dann
probier ich mich mal an, äh,
Castongrid-Eisenhofer.
Illuminator, wieso? Was
denn? Hab ich was übersehen?
Kann jetzt nicht so sehr auf Chat gucken
wie sonst.
Ich hab ein bisschen Currency gespart.
Also, so ein Budget-Ding, so ein halbwegs
budgetfähiges, äh,
Gear sollte ich mir
zusammen kaufen können.
Dann.
Hört sich teuer an. Ja,
ich denke, es ist billig
wird's net.
Also ich, ich hab
ungefähr, also ich hab grade im Stash,
aber ich hab noch sauviel Zeugs, was ich
verkaufen kann, was einfach nur rumliegt, wo ich bisher zu fault
war. Also,
Jebcock-Build, genau.
Na, Alter, das wollte ich gar nicht anklicken.
Also,
ich hab 5 Exols in der Kiste
und circa 270 Chaos in der
Kiste. Ich kann
noch mal relativ easy 3 Exols
aus Seeds machen. Und wenn
ich mal meine ganzen Kisten sortiere und
den ganzen Müll da mal
selle, dann wahrscheinlich
noch mal 1, 2, relativ easy. Also,
ich sollte ganz gut hinkommen. Natürlich
ist dafür keine super krasse
Explode, ähm,
Resi und, äh, Reflect
Chest und sowas drinne.
Die, die
kostet ja allein schon 10 bis 30 Exols.
Das sind ordentliche Chests, wenn man die nicht selbst
craften will. Das mach
ich nicht.
Versuch's mal ein bisschen. Bisschen mehr Budget.
Auf Budget.
Eine, die Waffen hab ich schon.
Für, ähm,
Ice Nova.
Ich mag's nicht nixor.
Das ist total unterschiedlich. Viele Leute
sagen, es ist geil.
Und dann gibt's auch ein paar wie mich,
die mögen das nicht. Weil ich
spiel am liebsten. Ich find dieses Crafting
einfach nur lästig. Aber
auch für mich ist die League geil. Und ich find's,
ich, ich fände es gut,
wenn es eine ähnliche Mechanik nächste League wieder
geben würde. Weil,
richtig kranke Items sind erschwinglicher
zum kaufen. Dadurch, dass es halt
einfach mehr gibt. Äh, und
ich kann Seeds verkaufen.
Seeds verkaufen ist übelst nice.
Einfach, einfach Maps farmen.
Und
die Seed Sellen.
Das bringt richtig, richtig
Asche.
Ja, Eislux. Genau, so mach ich's auch grade.
Du hast aufgehört zu zielen, weil's
kein Ziel mehr gab. Okay. Ja, aber genau dafür
sind die Leaks ja da. Ich, ich, wie gesagt,
ich hab's ja, ich hab's ja früher gespielt.
Noch, noch, da gab's auch noch keine Leaks und sowas.
Da gab's noch kein Vals und ich glaub
bei Dominos hat's aufgehört.
Das war wirklich ein bisschen doof.
Weil du hast halt ein gutes Build und hast dann,
oder hast zwei, drei gute Chars
gehabt und hast gedacht, na gut, was mach ich denn jetzt?
Aber durch das Leak-System, finde ich,
kann ich immer wieder
alle drei, dreieinhalb Monate
oder so, wann, wann eine Leak kommt,
kann ich immer ohne Probleme
zwei, zwei
Monate
regelmäßig spielen.
Halt mit regelmäßig mein ich halt nicht jeden
Tag zehn Stunden. Wenn ich jeden Tag zehn Stunden
spielen würde, hätte ich hier wahrscheinlich schon sonst was
an Bier und Gedöns am Start.
Ich bräuchte irgendwas. Cold Resistance!
Ja, exzellent, wunderbar.
Cold Resistance, das hab ich gebraucht.
Ja. Ja.
Ist egal, geh mal weg.
Cold Resistance brauch ich für den
Fighter jetzt. Jawoll, 70%.
Da kann sich die Olle
gleich mal verpissen. Da macht sie
kein Damage.
Gehst du dann auf die Leak-Challenges?
Nö.
Also mir reicht's, wenn ich pro Leak,
keine Ahnung, eins bis
vier Charakter mache
mit abwechslungsreichen Builds.
Da bin ich genug beschäftigt.
Und
dann hör ich so ungefähr einen Monat, bevor
Leak-Ende ist, aufzuspielen und warte auf die nächste Leak.
Das ist optimal für mich.
Wie gesagt, ich grinde keine 10 Stunden am Tag mehr wie früher.
Ich mach das am Wochenende.
Und in der Woche hab ich da keine Zeit zu, keinen Bock zu
oder was auch immer.
Oh, das ist ziemlich gut.
Übrigens, mal eine Empfehlung als Programm.
GitHub?
Richtig geiles Programm.
Ähm, PoE
Awaken Trade. Damit kann man sich,
damit bekommt man ein Overlay,
wo man schnelle
Preisabfragen machen kann. Ich mein, ist mir nur grad
eingefallen, weil ich gesagt hab, das Ding ist nicht schlecht.
Insgesamt gesehen ist das Amulett absoluter
Crap, ja. Aber, nur mal
so, zum, zum zeigen.
Ähm, Download.
Portable.
Ich zeig's euch mal. Das ist wirklich nice.
PoE Lurker hab ich
nicht, nee. Ich hab auf meinem anderen
Account hab ich noch ein paar Trade Addons.
Also für, für den Browser.
Trade Addon für den Browser.
Und, ähm,
Hallo? Kannst du mal aufgehen?
Äh, und dieses, ähm,
ich hab vergessen, wie es heißt, dieser
Trade Helper, der dir anzeigt,
wo in deinem Stash ein Trade,
was einer kaufen will, ist.
Ja, ist gut.
Monarch S.
RIP.
Virus ist raus.
So, ist jetzt gestartet.
Genau, und da drückt man einfach
Alt D, oder so.
Ich hab's bei mir auf
Alt D eingestellt, aber wahrscheinlich ist das hier nicht auf
Alt D Settings,
sondern...
A.
Alt.
D. F.
War Control D, aber ich hab's auf Alt D eingestellt.
Und jetzt kann man Preischeck
machen von den Items. Wie gesagt, ich weiß,
dass das nichts wert ist, aber, ähm,
das ist, das ist ultra praktisch.
Da kann man direkt,
direkt Preischeck machen auf,
äh, gegen die offizielle Trade API,
was man so für Items kriegt. Da kann man
zum Beispiel sagen, aha, okay, mein Tabula, was krieg ich dafür so?
Aha, so,
12 bis 15 Chaos.
Sehr praktisches Tool.
Was, wenn du mit dem Lurker auf der Trade Seite
anwespern möchtest, wird er sofort, ah, okay.
Muss ich mir mal angucken.
So, jetzt werde ich erstmal
sterben. Das ist,
das ist richtig sick, Kassadin.
Das ist richtig gut. Sonst krieg ich wahrscheinlich erstmal
auf den Sack. Please,
sterben.
Das wird gleich noch ein bisschen
schwieriger.
Ja, da kommen die Starcraft Skills durch hier.
Starter Step.
Oder auch nicht.
Fast.
Ich verreck hier.
Deswegen spiel ich kein Hardcore.
Vielleicht verreck ich doch nicht.
Ich hab, ich hab ja massig Cold Rats.
Eigentlich dürfte ich nicht verrecken.
So, easy.
Easy.
Ah, Akt 1 fertig.
Hat Tabula,
das Tabula, nee, das hat nichts.
Das ist ein
Ratsling zockelt.
Also, das ist wirklich nur zum Leveln und die ersten Maps zu gebrauchen.
Du hast halt null Defense mit dem Ding.
Es gibt auch noch ein paar
Leute, die hauen da Walorbs drauf,
dass du plus Skills drauf hast und sowas.
Das ist dann ein bisschen teurer, aber braucht man eigentlich nicht.
Ich will,
ehrlich gesagt, will ich einfach nur schnell 28
werden,
dass ich auf mein eigentliches Skillung, also auf mein eigentliche
Sache umswitchen kann
mit Gems.
Also, wenn du das auf den Rücken stellst,
geht mir schon echt auf den Keks.
Wenn es jetzt auch ganz gut Damage macht,
mittlerweile.
Aber in den ersten Nackenbrauen,
nein, du brauchst eigentlich
bis zum Schluss kein Sexling.
Also erst, wenn du Endgame spielst.
Es ist aber zum Leveln halt sehr praktisch.
Also, wenn du ein Level-Skillung machst
und ein Level-Gem-Setup,
wo was halt von Sexling profitiert.
Ich kann es beim Leveln gar nicht benutzen,
zum Beispiel,
wenn ich ein Mana reservieren würde.
Dann hätte ich überhaupt kein Mana mehr, um Sachen casten zu können,
wenn ich Sexling Spells länger mache beim Leveln.
So, jetzt muss ich mal kurz
Akt 1 zurück
und mein Zeug abholen.
So, ich brauch jetzt
eine Runde Toxic Rain.
Toxic Rain
und wie hieß das
andere nochmal?
Nee, Mirage Archer hab ich schon.
Toxic Rain.
Archer.
Void Manipulation.
Ist das klar?
Ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher.
Hat er hier auch die Skills drinnen?
Ich glaube, das ist die Kombi gewesen.
Toxic Rain.
Ich bin mir nicht mehr ganz sicher.
Mirage Archer Support.
Toxic Rain. Void Manipulation.
Ach, was auch immer.
Dash.
Ach, hier hätte ich sogar ein Frost Blink gekriegt.
Lull.
Pack Triple U.
I don't think I need to be doing that.
Well, stay sharp out there.
Ja, bist dein Captain Peng.
Mal kurz gucken.
Ich hatte doch eben ein Video auf,
gerade, wo ich das
hergezogen hab.
Das hab ich.
Frost Blink, das hab ich auch.
Was macht der sonst noch hier?
Ach, Faster Attacks
war's.
Wo gab's denn Faster Attacks?
P.O.E.
Gab's das auch bei Nessa?
Oder wo gab's den Kram?
Ah!
Bandit Quest.
Alles klar. Gut, dann muss ich das mal ein bisschen spielen.
Excellent.
Aber da platzen sie.
Beast Bashen.
Zone 14.
Ich bin 15.
Optimales Level hierfür eigentlich.
Kann der mal sterben?
Hopp.
Denied.
Die Quest mach ich einzig und alleine
nur,
dass ich noch eine Flask kriege.
Glaube zumindest, dass das die Quest ist,
wo man noch eine Flask kriegt.
Wie gesagt, ich hab mir
selbst für mich so ein Mini-Guide aufgeschrieben
mit ein paar Punkten drauf, dass ich nicht immer beim Leveln
Sachen vergesse.
Aber ich glaub, ich hab so manche, diese Sachen hab ich natürlich
nicht aufgeschrieben, was das hier für eine Quest war.
Ich glaub, das ist die Flaschen, vielleicht weiß es einer von euch.
Ich glaub, das ist die Quest, wo man die zweite Flasche
kriegt.
Achso, du kriegst ein Book of Skill?
Nee, oder?
Hier kriegt man die zweite Flasche.
Die erste Flasche
hab ich schon.
Ich glaub aber, hier gibt's die zweite Flasche.
Sehen wir jetzt ja gleich.
Na ja,
zweite Flasche.
Oh, ist ganz gut.
Kann man sogar dreimal zünden.
Äh...
Jetzt haben wir eh wieder ordentlich Mana.
Das sagt zwar, ja.
Jetzt...
Oh, jetzt können wir ein bisschen Gas geben hier.
Hui!
Können wir hier durchsausen.
So, jetzt machen wir die Bandits.
Und ein bisschen leveln.
Look nice!
Jetzt rushen wir durch zu den Bandits.
Machen rechts die Bridge.
Ich laber nur ein bisschen laut
vor mich hin, weil...
Ich muss mir jetzt merken, was ich machen muss.
Ich geh jetzt zur Brücke, kill den Bandit
auf der Brücke, dann geh ich hoch.
Mach Chamber auf Sins,
geh zurück, andere Seite Bandits.
So, das machen wir jetzt.
Wenn ich das richtig in Erinnerung hab.
Ansonsten guck ich in meinen Guide.
Pass mal auf, nächstes Jahr mach ich hier
Speedrun World Record. Easy.
Cool.
Was wir gesehen haben, die richtig guten Speedrunners,
die halten sich kaum auf, Gegner
zu killen. Die haben da eine richtig gute Taktik,
wann was angeschossen wird.
Und wann, äh...
Wann quasi Packs gekillt werden und wann nicht.
Aber guck mal,
nachdem ich das geskillt hab, hab ich jetzt immer voll Mana
und voll Leben. Das ist gut so.
Excellent.
Da kann ja nix mal schief gehen hier.
Da platzen sie.
Ja.
Die machen, ähm...
Die Speedrunner machen noch,
die machen die Kombi aus Smokemine,
Smokemine
und, ähm, Dash
glaube ich spielen die.
Also die können so ein Double, Double
Sprint Jump machen.
So, Kollege, get rekt.
Wo ist er denn? Ich seh den überhaupt nicht.
Please, verrecken.
Let's go.
Ich meine, ist ja nicht so,
als macht der jetzt wahnsinnig Damage
mit Life Leech und allem drum herum.
Ja, next.
Wow.
So.
Jetzt gehen wir zum Waypoint, gehen eine Zone zurück,
gehen hoch, Chamber of Sins.
28, ich komme.
Da freu ich mich schon drüber.
28 drauf.
28 und endlich ordentliches
Spellslinger Setup.
Wobei, so richtig gut wird das Spellslinger
Setup dann erst im...
Im Act drauf.
Weil erst dann
krieg ich hier multiple
Projects.
Nicht Projekte, Projektile
meine ich.
Dann wird das richtig OP zum Leveln.
Das ist das schnellste Level Setup,
was es aktuell gibt.
Zumindest der
der aktuelle
Speedrun Weltrekord
hat das auch gehabt.
Chaos Spellslinger
mit
bisschen Support noch dabei.
Man macht dann
drei Spellslinger.
Soulrend, Contagion
und
äh
was ist das dritte?
Ich muss gleich mal nachgucken.
Man legt zumindest
dreimal Spellslinger
und
oneshotted den ganzen Bildschirm im Endeffekt.
Während man levelt.
Später in Maps natürlich
ohne Investition nicht.
Das brauch ich eigentlich auch nicht.
So, jetzt müssen wir den Boss hier bashen.
Wollen wir ihn finden?
Was ich auch an Path of Exile mag
ist
das hat so ein
eigenen Flow
vor allem im Endgame.
Du kannst das
stundenlang spielen. Bei Diablo habe ich
Anfälle gekriegt, bei Diablo 3.
Diablo 2 nicht.
Das konnte ich mir nicht lange angucken.
Ich kann Maps 12 Stunden
am Stück machen und bin danach
nicht komplett braindead.
Brauch ich nicht, hab ich schon.
Das habe ich in Diablo 3
nicht hingekriegt.
Übrigens totaler Crap.
Wir können zählen.
Das ist das schlimme an PoE.
Warum ich finde es gut.
Ist doch top für ein Game
wenn du es lange spielen kannst
ohne dass du im Kopf danach komplett hinüber bist.
Also sowas wie zum Beispiel
Warzone kann ich keine 12 Stunden
am Stück spielen. Das ist mir viel zu anstrengend.
TF, was ist denn jetzt los?
Alter, was ist mit dem Typ?
Ach, das ist ein 1er Beast.
Oh, an dem mache ich ja
Huge Damage, Leute.
Massive Damage.
Jetzt übertreiben sie es aber hier mit
OKS.
Aber gut hier.
Da bin ich nicht equipped für.
Jetzt ist es down.
Excellent.
Dafür gab das richtig EXP gerade.
Irgendwas dabei, was ich gleich
brauche.
Äh, Scrolls
kann man nicht genutzen.
Live Flask.
Large Mana Flask.
Das recovered
mehr als das?
Crap.
Was?
Suckt, Alter.
Instant Mana.
Echt?
Also ich kann Path of Exile
echt 10 Stunden am Stück spielen und bin
voll entspannt.
Und das sage ich, obwohl ich hier
übelstes
Effekt
Feuerwerkbild spiele auf mein Main.
Aber ich glaube, das
liegt auch daran, weil Path of Exile eine gute
Abwechslung hat aus
Moment,
laufe ich überhaupt richtig?
Aus irgendwie ingame
rumgecrimed, allerdings immer ein bisschen
unterschiedliche Settings durch die Maps.
Ab und zu mal ein bisschen traden
über die Seite. Dann ein bisschen
Gear checken.
Weltseite lurken.
Hast du schon mal Level 100 gecrimed? Nein.
Das höchste war glaube ich
6 oder 97.
Mein Main ist aktuell glaube
93 oder 94.
Ich glaube 93.
Man muss halt echt aufpassen,
dass man bei manchen doofen Sachen nicht stirbt.
Das Game hat halt so eine Sache,
die mir damals in Diablo 2 schon auf den Keks
gegangen ist. Was aber auch irgendwie passt, weil
die Entwickler selbst sagen, dass Diablo 2
Inspiration war.
Game is easy as fuck.
Und auf einmal stirbst du instant.
Kennt wahrscheinlich
ein paar.
Easy as fuck, du gehst durch
bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, alles tot.
Dann gehst du hoch, was war das?
Und dann hast du festgestellt, ah ok,
Gegner hatte scheiß Mods für mein
Setup und ich bin down.
So.
Jetzt machen wir Speedrun 360
und
gehen zur Character Selection.
Das ist Speedrun Hex.
Deswegen würde ich PoE nie Hardcore zocken.
Ne, das könnte ich auch nicht.
Äh, ja. Excellent.
Bisschen, bisschen in Damage
bis 26, beziehungsweise 28.
Schaut's euch was? Wir holen. Ne, ne.
War das später.
Kurz den Kram sellen.
Leider.
So, nächster Bandit.
Ja, so ist es.
Vor allem, manche Bosse
sind teilweise auch, also gerade die Metamorphs
sind teilweise gar nicht zu erkennen,
was sie jetzt machen.
Es ist grau in grau in grau,
es plubbert ein bisschen rum
und auf einmal
jumpt das Ding dann auf dich oder
one-shotted dich mit irgendwas, also.
Was ist eigentlich in dem Chat gerade los?
Der Chat ist so hilfreich.
Normalerweise ist gerade der deutsche
Path of Exile Chat eher am trollen.
Warum ist der Chat
so hilfreich?
Das stimmt doch irgendwas nicht.
In welchem Chat bin ich denn hier gelandet?
Der Main Chat und hilfreich.
Was ist das für eine Kombi?
Wobei ich die Path of Exile Community
finde ich nicht übel.
Ähm.
Gerade der Main Chat ist
trolling
as fuck, aber
das ist nicht so toxic rumge...
schon ein bisschen, aber nicht so
fuck your mom mäßig,
sondern die schreiben halt irgendeinen
Müll im Endeffekt rum, weil sie es lustig
finden. Ähm.
Aber ansonsten ist Path of Exile halt eine echt
extrem entspannte Community.
Es gibt natürlich auch hier
ein paar Scammer, aber es ist
ein Unterschied, ob dich einer beim Trade scammt
oder ob einer deine Mutter beleidigt,
weil du gerade deinen Heal-File
nicht getroffen hast, so. Wisst ihr, wie ich meine?
Äh, hier will
ich nicht lang. Moment, warte mal.
Äh, doch, Wetlands.
Wetlands. Ich bin doch richtig.
Ich bin doch richtig.
Ich muss jetzt hier den Bandit bashen.
Aber gerade auch,
wenn ihr euch mal Path of...
Ich muss skillen. Wenn ihr euch Path of Exile
ähm...
Streams anguckt,
da ist ganz wenig
toxic Bullshit dabei.
Eigentlich heftig, ja.
Also, es dürfte eines der
family friendliest games
auf Twitch sein, ne?
Von der Community her.
Genau, genau. Ja, gerade deswegen.
Es ist halt kein PvP.
Moin. Leku.
Vor allem ist es halt auch kein competitive
mit Ranking gedöhntes PvP.
Da sind es natürlich noch mehr toxic alle.
Was geht mit dem hier ab?
Gucken wir mal, ob da mal vielleicht eine gescheite...
Haben wir hier vielleicht mal ein paar gescheite
Handschuhe?
Ah!
Ja, doch sogar.
Moment, das kann ich mir immer nicht merken. Macht das
ein Defizit?
Wo geht es hier rein? Irgendwo ist doch hier der Bandit.
Ich glaube, der ist ein bisschen mehr in der Mitte, ne?
Ah!
Da ist er.
Ja, gerade deswegen finde ich Path of Exile
echt angenehm.
Mich hat es jetzt in
Overwatch nicht so extrem
gestört.
Also jetzt beispielsweise in Overwatch.
Natürlich war das
teilweise schon toxic as fuck.
Aber man konnte
es einfach als dummes Geschwätze abtun. Aber
es war trotzdem anstrengend.
Weil halt gerade Overwatch auch so
ein komplettes
Sinnes-Overload-Game ist.
Das ist nicht so,
wie du irgendwie jetzt
keine Ahnung, Valorant, CS oder
was auch immer, das kannst du
8 Stunden am Stück spielen und es geht eigentlich.
Aber
ähm, Dings
du kannst halt kein Overwatch
8 Stunden am Stück spielen, ohne im Kopf
komplett im Arsch zu sein.
Weil Overwatch ist halt permanent.
Und du kannst den Overwatch auch
permanent verlieren.
Ich mein, ich weiß immer noch nicht, was
Blizzard geritten hat, dass man
irgendwie, keine Ahnung,
unendlich viel Overtime bekommt, auch wenn
das andere Team dich zerrissen hat
vorher und sowas. Keine Ahnung, also ich find's
ich find Overwatch an vielen Stellen nicht
fair.
Und von so Sachen wie 2CP reden wir erstmal gar nicht.
Ähm,
deswegen war es halt doppelt abgefuckt,
wenn du so dumm verloren hast.
Zumal Overwatch halt auch
ähm, gerade
dadurch, dass es
bis auf ein paar
Ausnahmen an Helden
nicht so war, dass du extrem carry'n
konntest. SlaydaTeddy
Dankeschön, 5 Monate.
Excellent Subscription, Dankeschön.
Ähm, war halt auch dieses
Team-Blaming immer übelst am Start, ne?
Das war halt auch anstrengend.
So, jetzt müssen wir
Allera noch bashen.
Könnte hier oben irgendwo sein, wenn wir Glück haben.
Parrier Crater Life.
Ja, kann man nicht genug haben.
Moment, warum?
Okay, das hat sich jetzt nicht so wirklich gelohnt.
So, wo stellst
Allera rum?
Ist ne Grand Mana
Flux besser? 170? Ja,
auf jeden Fall.
Moin, Risk Dipper.
Äh, komplett in die falsche
Richtung gelandet, Alter. Ich muss
Blackguards machen, ich muss Allera machen.
Man erkennt das übrigens irgendwo. Ich hab letztens
bei irgendeinem Speedrun-Dude gesehen,
dass man anhand der Positionierung
vom Waypoint
kann man irgendwie erkennen,
wie die Map aufgebaut ist.
Endlich pass ich dich mal ab.
Äh, ich war vorher schon on, und da haben wir
normale Sachen gemacht.
Und nun, ähm, wollte ich halt
ein bisschen Passive Exile, einen neuen Charakter leveln.
Und der Stream-Chat meinte,
ich kann's ja auch on stream machen.
Ich hab gesagt, ich wusste, dass das hier nicht so wahnsinnig viel
interessiert, aber warum nicht?
Ein paar scheint's ja doch zu interessieren.
Und bevor ich jetzt hier
alleine vor mich hin hocke,
oder im Stream, dann ist doch
im Stream nicht ganz so langweilig.
So, wir müssen noch Allera
bashen. Wo ist sie denn?
Allera, komm her!
Würdest PoE-Streams
gerne öfters sehen? Ja, die meisten
glaub ich nicht.
Ich mach ja auch sonst was ganz was anderes.
Aber eine schöne
Sache auf Twitch ist, hier machen's
die Leute wirklich so, wenn sie, wenn sie
das nicht so sehr interessiert, dann gucken sie sich halt nicht an.
Und auf YouTube hast du dann die Kommentare
voll mit irgendwelchem Kram.
So nach dem Motto, Max, das ist
nicht der Content, wofür ich dir abonniert hab. Max,
mach doch endlich wieder mal ein gutes Video. Max,
früher waren deine Videos aber besser. Weißt du, mach's mal
ein Video, was irgendwie nicht gut ankommt,
gleich, äh, rumgemeckert.
Das ist auf Twitch nicht so. Auf Twitch
hast du viel Auswahl, auf Twitch guckst du dann einfach was
anderes. Solange der, ich, ich
würde auch nie auf die Idee kommen, Leute, auf, ich bin
noch nicht einem.
Sag ich jetzt einfach mal so, weil ich bin mir nicht
ganz sicher, noch nicht einem, dem ich
gefollowt bin, bisher entfollowt auf Twitch.
Ich guck einfach nur die Sachen, die mir gefallen,
den Rest lass ich halt aus. Fertig.
Das ist nicht wie auf YouTube, so nach dem
Motto, oh Max, du wirst immer schlechter, Diabo.
Rätst doch mal mehr Leute im Gameplay, genau.
So sieht's aus.
Aber das
konnte, das war ja noch, das war ja noch
inhaltliche Kritik. Ich soll mehr Leute
wiederbeleben in Battlefield. Da konnte ich
ja verstehen. Das ist ja,
das ist ja okay, da habe ich nichts dagegen.
Aber auf YouTube sind dann teilweise so
unsinnige
Sachen.
Aber es ist halt
so, es war, es war zumindest
lange so, mittlerweile sind wir gerade auf
Twitch Deutschland jetzt auch nicht unbedingt
auf dem, wie soll man sagen,
intellektuell aufsteigenden
Ast, ja.
Aber es war
lange Jahre so und da bin ich auch immer,
bin ich immer noch davon überzeugt, dass es
immer noch so ist, dass
auf YouTube mehr
low, low brain
Leute rumlaufen als auf Twitch.
Twitch ist deutlich big brainiger.
Ich laufe übrigens komplett
verkehrt, da oben ist, da oben geht's runter.
Twitch hat deutlich mehr
brain als YouTube im Durchschnitt.
Ausnahmen gibt's immer, klar,
du hast Deppen auf Twitch,
Deppen auf YouTube, aber du hast auf
YouTube mehr.
Es sieht man ja auch schon ganz
klar, guckt euch mal, wie viele dumm, dumm
Channels es gibt. Gibt auf Twitch
auch immer mehr, gerade YouTube Deutschland ist irgendwie
mittlerweile...
Aber ich, ich
verfolge YouTube Deutschland eh.
Aber was, was gucke ich in YouTube Deutschland?
Lass mal kurz überlegen. Denn beim Lost gucke ich
ab und zu mal,
ähm, aber auch
gerade kein Modern Warfare, weil mich das nicht so
großartig juckt, wenn spiele ich es manchmal Laps.
Ähm, beim Lost gucke ich
ab und zu,
ich gucke Zelda Speedruns
auf Deutsch,
mit deutschem Commentary manchmal.
Ähm, was gucke ich denn sonst noch?
Was, was gucke ich sonst noch
auf Twitch Deutschland?
Mir, mir fällt jetzt wirklich nichts ein.
Ich gucke, okay,
okay, ich, ich gucke mal kurz,
du folgst, okay, du folgst,
also, du folgst.
Wer, wem, wem folge ich?
Wer ist, wer ist hier deutschsprachig?
Also,
zeig mal her.
Geh mal, geh mal, geh mal hier durch.
Sind relativ viele.
Okay, Asmongold, äh,
Esamarathon, Huskers, Follow Krabby,
Amon, Shadow2k,
das ist alles nichts deutsches.
Seagull,
Bob Ross, ähm,
Dreamhack CS,
Diablo 2 Speedruns,
der Lost, der Lost kommt jetzt hier als nächstes mit
692,
697 Zuschauen.
Der einzige,
ja, deutsches Streamer, den ich ab und zu gucke.
So, und dann
haben wir hier noch Speedrun, Speedrun, Speedrun,
bisschen Overwatch.
Die Märchenstunde mit der
Oma ist am Start. Okay, die wusste ich gar nicht,
dass ich die noch gesubbt hab. Aber wie gesagt,
ich, ich, ich end Subbrick, also ich end Follow
auf Twitch auch keinem.
Speedrun, Speedrun, Speedrun und, äh,
Zelda Speedrun auf Deutsch. Ne, war's.
War das, was ich gesagt hab. Ansonsten
guck ich nix auf Twitch
Deutschland.
Auch, äh,
nur,
naja, nur Müll kann man nicht sagen, aber
wenig, wenig, wenig dabei, was mich
halt interessiert.
Faster Casting? Ne.
Faster Casting brauchen wir nicht.
Wir brauchen Faster Attacks.
Faster Casting?
Warum hat der, ah!
Warum hat der Faster Casting
keine Faster, ah doch, der hat noch Faster Attacks.
Was laber ich denn? Alter Max, was
laberst du für'n Scheiß, ey.
Faster Attacks.
Kack Noob.
So, jetzt müssen wir mal umsockeln.
Endlich kann ich mal das Ding verwenden.
Was ist jetzt besser, das
oder das?
Rater? Ne, das ist Müll.
Brauch ich gar net. Destroy.
Weg. Destroy.
Brauch ich auch net. Alles, alles sellen.
Komm, wisst
ihr was? Wir machen mal ein
Inflare. Wo ist die Kiste?
Machen wir mal ein Inflare.
Äh, Portal Scrolls.
Verhalten wir.
Äh, für was ist das nochmal gut?
Ach, das brauch ich in Akt 1.
Akt 1 muss ich auch noch meine Skillbooks abholen.
Ich kack Noob. Null.
So, und dann ist Akt 2 eigentlich auch schon fast fertig.
Oh, ne.
Kann das sein, dass ich...
Hab ich das vergessen zu machen?
Ich glaub, ich hab's
nicht geöffnet, ne?
Oh, ne.
Braucht man das?
Das hab ich verkackt jetzt.
Äh, ich glaub, ich hab vergessen, das Portal
zu öffnen zu Akt 1.
Na, zum Glück ist die Map noch da.
Na, rushen wir jetzt mal schnell durch.
Weil sonst wär Akt 2 fast schon
fertig gewesen. Ja, guckt da unten.
Ich hab's vergessen aufzumachen.
Lolololololololololol.
Weil ich mir gar nicht sicher bin,
ob man das für Skillpoints überhaupt braucht.
Stimmt. Ja.
Hab ich gar nicht dran gedacht, Galax.
Oh, Skill.
Jawoll.
Weiß jemand aus dem Kopf, was man am Ende
äh, für Skillpoints
hat, wenn man alle Skillpoints macht von Quests
und Banditen? Ich glaub 24,
oder?
Ich bin übrigens Kacknub und hab den Waypoint nicht
genommen.
Was nicht wild ist, weil man kann hier direkt reinlaufen.
Aber...
Wieso nicht einfach Portal Scroll nutzen, weil ich keine
Portal Scrolls, äh, nicht so viel Portal Scrolls
hab?
Und weil's schneller geht.
Oh, wir sind auf dem Weg zu Spellslinger.
Ich kann diesen Pfeilstells hier nicht
mehr mit angucken.
So, Act 2 gleich durch.
Ups. Vielleicht soll ich nicht
so viel Chat gucken.
Äh, Chat, ich muss mal schnell was schauen.
Mal kurz was gucken bei Twitch.
Lolololololololololol.
So, weiter.
Skill, Skill, Skill.
Okay, äh,
Pice of Building. Wo muss man jetzt lang?
Leech, Life.
Eigentlich leech ich genug
live. Das brauche ich eigentlich nicht. Das machen wir mal. Das ist safer. Das ist safer. Wir machen erstmal ein bisschen
Live-Leach. Ja, Live-Leach. Das da, das da. Und dann gehen wir hoch auf Damage. Da kriegen wir auch ein bisschen
hier Decks und Punkte und Gedöns, alles. Bis hierhin gehen wir und dann gehen wir hoch den
Intree. So, mal gucken, ob wir jetzt schnell durchkommen. 20. Ja, wir sind eigentlich ganz gut.
Ich glaube, das ist immer ein ganz gutes Indikator, wenn man ungefähr Level von der Zone ist, dass man
sich nicht so lange aufgehalten hat mit sinnlos rumstehen und bashen, sondern einfach zügig
durchgeht. Ja, toll. Kann man den Kram da unten eigentlich ausschalten, die Questmarker? Nervt
mich immer. Ich weiß ja im Prinzip, wo ich lang muss. Übrigens, ich bin gerade am überlegen. Leute,
die manchmal den Stream...
bei mir normalerweise gucken, wissen ja, ich habe einen 10 Gigabit Ubiquity Switch. Und ich bin gerade
am überlegen, ob ich den nicht verkaufen soll und mir irgendwas kleineres holen soll, weil ich brauche
keine 12 Ports, 12 Gigabit. Ich habe mir jetzt überlegt, ob ich mir nicht doch noch einen kleineren
Mikrotik-Switch hole. Irgendwie, keine Ahnung, 150 Euro. Und den Ubiquity Switch verkaufe.
Allerdings glaube ich, kann ich den nicht richtig verkaufen, weil ich hab den Lüfter gemoddet.
Ja, ich weiß, warum sollte man bei einem Switch den Lüfter modden?
Ja, ich...
Er war mir halt ein bisschen zu laut.
Da hab ich halt einen anderen Lüfter dran gemacht.
Case Modding beim Switch.
Aber trotzdem.
Eigentlich blöd, weil jetzt quäle ich das Ding immer los.
Auf der anderen Seite ist der Switch nicht schlecht.
Der hat massig Ports, auch ein paar Gigabit.
Aber halt hauptsächlich 10G.
Alter, wo geht's denn lang?
Da, da geht's lang.
Aber ich hab mir halt gedacht, ich verkauf den.
Insane Speedrunner, massive Speedrunner.
Und ich kauf mir dann halt einen 2-4 Port 10G von Mikrotik.
Und...
Halt, dann...
Dann hab ich noch mit Gigabit-Ports dran.
So alles in einem.
Aber eigentlich ist es eher nice to have.
Und letztendlich komplett sinnlos.
Hab die Lüfterplatine von meinem Server moddet.
Ja, warum auch nicht?
Das ist eigentlich eine gute Sache.
Wir sind auch viele Sachen zu laut.
Äh, renn ich denn hier lang, Alter?
Also ich hab den...
Den Server, den ich...
Die 4AE-Kiste hab ich.
Also die hier.
Die hab ich euch ja schon ein paar Mal gezeigt.
Die hier.
Jetzt gucken, dass ich nicht verrecke.
Äh, die hab ich ja auch soweit Lüfter moddet,
dass...
Hier sind nur Noctua-Lüfter drin.
Noctua-Lüfter vor Noctua und Noctua-Lüfter auf der CPU.
Weil der mir sonst viel zu laut war mit den Default-Lüftern.
Switch hab ich auch in Noctua-Lüfter reingemacht.
Weil der mir sonst zu laut war.
Mich und den Friseur auf YouTube.
Der Friseur, der hat eine ganze...
Der hat eine ganze Weile auch gestreamt.
Macht der, glaube ich, irgendwelche Mobile-Games in letzter Zeit noch.
Komm, einer.
Sammle ein.
Boah, was hält denn das Ding aus?
WTF?
Was ist das wieder für ein Gegner?
Mal hier.
Da brauchen wir drei Stunden.
Jetzt erstmal den Akt abschließen.
Wie gesagt, der Akt ist mehr oder weniger durch.
Jetzt kommt jetzt nur noch der Boss.
Zack.
So, wir skillen.
Einmal Int.
Weil wir brauchen Int.
Dass ich Flameless weiter hochleveln kann.
Äh, iFrisi.
Ja, genau.
So heißt er auf Twitch.
Aber der war jetzt in letzter Zeit nicht mehr so oft on.
Marc spielt PoE.
Ja, seit zwei Leaks wieder.
Letzte League hab ich nicht so viel gespielt.
Account ist von 2013.
Und ich hab ja extra heute davor nochmal normal gestreamt.
Weil ich ja wusste,
dass ich jetzt einfach mal
acht Stunden PoE anschmeiße,
denke ich, die meisten Leute,
was ist jetzt los?
Oh, ich bin bei 28.
Ich kann diesen Bogenstelz
mit dem mal angucken.
Ihr insane Speedrun-Strats.
Die richtigen Speedrun-Sore,
die haben hier noch Smokemine am Start
und klitschen sich durch jede Öffnung durch.
Ups.
Geht sogar noch weiter.
Lol.
Komm hier, Map.
Map, mach mit.
Ja, aber eigentlich ist das Tabula
ziemlich sinnvoll.
Oder Tabular, wie die Amis immer sagen.
Das triggert mich immer,
wenn es das hat,
nein, nein, ich spiel keine Hardcore.
Ich find das immer geil,
wenn die Amis sagen Tabular.
Ich sag Tabular, Alter.
Tabular.
Ähm.
Eigentlich ist es aber sinnlos gerade,
weil ich zum Leveln maximal vier Link brauche.
Das einzig Gute ist,
ich muss keine Sockel suchen,
sondern kann einfach sockeln, ne?
Wie ich lustig bin.
Könntest du noch den Account linken?
Ach, okay.
Eigentlich gar nicht schlecht.
Ja, das, das guck ich mir mal an.
Das guck ich mir mal an.
Das find ich cool.
Aber ich wäre eh nicht zum großen, äh...
Sag mal.
Ach, da ohne geht's lang.
Hätte ich auch mal gleich sehen können.
Zum krassen PoE-Only-Streamer.
Ich mach, ich mach schon mal ein Zeug weiter.
Letztendlich finde ich es auch richtig nice auf Twitch, ne?
Zumal jetzt hier auch...
Also, Leute, jetzt hier, da sind hier so die Hardcore-Zuschauer.
Ähm.
Ich find's halt auch auf Twitch richtig nice,
dass, ähm,
ich hier überhaupt so Kram machen kann,
wie ich's auf Twitch mache.
Ich mein, wer guckt sich denn großartig an,
also auf YouTube oder so,
wenn ich beispielsweise
einen Reverse-Proxy einrichte
auf
einem Digital Ocean Server,
um dort irgendwelche Sachen auszuprobieren.
Das ist halt
auf YouTube...
voll für'n Arsch.
Aber hier auf Twitch ist halt nice.
Und es gibt ja auch, wenn man ehrlich ist,
wen gibt's dann auf Twitch noch, der sowas macht?
Also, ich will nicht sagen, dass ich der Einzige bin, der sowas macht.
Ne, das ist ja nie...
Aber so viele Channels in der Richtung,
die sich auch mal im Detail mit sowas auseinandersetzen,
gibt's doch nicht, oder?
Wer fällt euch noch ein?
Nein, nein, ich mein das nicht hier auf Twitch.
Ich mein, ich mein auf YouTube.
Auf YouTube guckt das keiner was.
Dass hier viele Leute gucken, die so was machen.
Dass hier viele Leute gucken zum Lernen, weiß ich.
Ist ja auch klar, deswegen mach ich's ja auch.
Deswegen erklär ich ja auch die ein oder anderen Sachen noch dabei.
Also...
Aber so viele gibt's da auf Twitch nicht,
die das, ähm...
in der Richtung machen.
Es gibt einige Programmier-Streams,
das hab ich schon gesehen.
Mehr, als ich ursprünglich eigentlich gedacht hab.
Auch welche mit gar nicht so wenig Zuschauern.
Also gar nicht so wenig Zuschauern,
was Programmieren angeht, sind so, keine Ahnung, maximal 300.
Dann ist's, äh, vorbei.
Aber...
die so ein bisschen Linux-mäßig was machen,
gibt's nicht viel.
Und ich versuch mir ja auch immer Themen auszudenken,
mit denen man was anfangen kann, ne?
Also zum Beispiel letztens
diese Traffic-Reverse-Proxy-Geschichte
mit Docker-Container, sowas.
Das ist was, das bringt vielen Leuten daheim was,
die zum Beispiel ihre Nextcloud
von außen, äh...
zugreifbar machen wollen, und sowas.
Und ich sag ja dann auch immer noch ein paar Takte dabei.
Also ich sag ja dann immer noch dabei, Leute, ich...
ich würd's euch nicht empfehlen, einfach so,
auch wenn es damit geht, ich würd's euch nicht empfehlen,
die Sache einfach so ins Internet zu stellen,
weil halt, äh...
wenn Authentifizierung
Probleme hat, dann...
jeder kann sich eure Nextcloud-Sachen angucken.
Ich versuch dann auch immer noch ein bisschen drumherum zu erzählen,
so nach dem Motto, ja, was würde ich stattdessen machen,
stattdessen würde ich, ähm...
wenn's geht, ein VPN
benutzen, wenn ich's schon von außen zugreifbar machen würde,
und sowas.
Also ich versuch ja schon die Sachen auch so zu machen,
dass die Leute was von haben.
Aber trotzdem gibt's, find ich, nicht so viel auf Twitch,
in der Richtung, und für mich ist's halt nice,
weil ich hätte
nie gedacht, dass ich mal mit, äh...
so Technikkram...
Und es ist ja, da müssen wir ehrlich sagen,
jetzt mal, Leute,
true 0w, ne? Man muss ja mal ehrlich sagen,
was wir hier für Technik-Sachen
im Stream machen,
ist schon ein bisschen
advanced.
Also das hat nix mit zu tun, wie, ähm...
keine Ahnung, wie...
klicke ich mir unter Windows...
...
Also das ist schon teilweise relativ
advanced, muss man sagen.
Und das ist so advanced, dass da auch, äh...
Leute, die in dem Bereich arbeiten,
sich durchaus erstmal einlesen müssen,
und das nicht einfach mal so nebenbei aus dem Ärmel
schütteln, ja?
Und das gibt's ja so gar nicht.
Und das find ich halt cool, dass man auch so
advancede Sachen machen kann,
und ich hätte nie gedacht, dass mir da
so viele Leute bei zugucken.
Guck mal, wir haben teilweise...
...haben wir, gut, jetzt mal bei den
Apple-Events außen vor, mit 700 Zuschauern,
0, ähm...
Aber im Durchschnitt, wenn man was halbwegs Interessantes,
Technisches macht, auch was, was durchaus
anspruchsvoll ist, haben wir 200
Zuschauer. 150, sag mal so
150 bis 250, schwankt.
Ähm...
Und...
Auch sonntags, wo wir im Prinzip einfach nur
sinnlose Reaction, sinnloser
Reaction-Content machen, ja?
Haben wir auch teilweise, manchmal,
manchmal sogar bis 300, wo ich immer denke,
the fuck?
Und das alles, und da bin ich auch ganz froh,
ich hab ja nie großartig Werbung gemacht,
auf YouTube auch,
und
was ich cool finde, dass hier auch mittlerweile
viele da sind, die gar nicht über
YouTube gekommen sind, sondern das einfach so gefunden haben.
Das ist echt
nice.
Dank mir hast du den Serverraum zu Hause.
Das ist cool.
Was hast du für einen Server drinstehen?
Oder, was hast du für Geräte drinstehen?
Im Serverraum muss ja nicht zwangsläufig ein Server stehen.
Kack, nur Boss, Alter.
Ololololo.
Au.
Boss, Boss, kannst du mal sterben.
Please.
So.
Excellent. Oh, wisst ihr, was mir
grad auffällt? Ich spiel die ganze Zeit
ohne Köcher. Lol.
Hahaha.
Ist mir gar nicht aufgefallen.
Aber, brauchen wir nicht.
Overrated.
So, Akt 3.
Das, und jetzt gehen wir
hoch auf
direkt int,
würd ich sagen, ne?
Ah, nee, hier rum gehen wir.
Etwas unoptimiertes Bild.
Egal, ich respeck da eben
dann was später.
Oh ja, in vier
Level spiel ich
Spells länger.
Das halt ich jetzt auch noch aus.
Weiß ich nicht, ob
der tot genervt ist, keine Ahnung.
Mach mal played.
Eine Stunde, 48.
Geht das für Anfang Akt 3?
Ich weiß, dass das Speedrun-mäßig übelst
Müll ist, ist mir klar.
Aber so rein aus Noob-Casual-Sicht.
Wie gesagt, in doppelter
Zeit war Taitai Killer
3.30 den Akt 10
durch. Lol.
Auf, Clarissa, steh auf.
Kogas, dankeschön, acht Monate.
So, drei Level
noch, exzellent.
Drei Level noch, da kann
ich endlich Spells länger umrüsten.
Von der Seite bin ich ja schon lange nicht mehr
reingelaufen, oder kommt man nicht, nee, man kommt immer
in die Seite rein von Akt 2.
So, Slums.
Wir gehen erst gar nicht in die Stadt runter.
So,
Krematorium müssen wir jetzt,
wenn ich das richtig in Erinnerung
hab. Wie gesagt, Akt 1,
2, 3, 4
kann ich halbwegs auswendig.
Krematorium müssen wir.
Einzige Sache, wo ich
immer noch ein bisschen drauf achten muss, ist,
dass ich alle Skill-Quests mache.
Das heißt, da muss ich dann zwischendurch mal gucken,
dass ich keine Skill-Quests
übersehe. Ach ja, und
Harvest sammel ich nicht auf,
weil die Low-Seeds bringen
eh nix. Onkka.
Die paar extra kannst du
mit Passives nachschauen, ja.
Stimmt, ja.
So, wo ist das Krematorium?
Es geht meistens über solche Brücken drüber
und dann ist es am Ende der Map irgendwo.
Vielleicht hier?
Es ist immer irgendwo am Ende
der Map, nachdem man über so ein paar
Brücken gerannt ist. Da ist es doch.
So.
Und wenn ich es jetzt hier richtig in Erinnerung
hab, muss ich...
gar nicht richtig sicher, ob ich ein Stockwerk runter
muss oder ob ich direkt, ob der
Boss hier direkt ist. Ich glaub, der ist direkt
hier.
Massive Speedrun.
Boah, ey! Geh!
Kaputt! Vieh!
Die bringen immer dick XP.
Aber das Mana-Leach und Live-Leach,
das hat sich schon ausgezahlt gemacht zu specken.
Bin ich deutlich weniger
fragil als am Anfang.
Ich guck dann, ob ich paar
Skill-Quests übersehen hab,
aber...
Moment, da unten ist die Trial.
Die brauch ich nicht, die hab ich schon.
Aha, hier sind wir.
Ach, jetzt kommt der Kram.
Einmal Piety bashen.
Loot Boss.
Ja, ich hab Lightning Resist.
Da machst du nix, ne?
Piss dich, Alde.
Die hat nicht mit
Resist gerechnet, da.
Kann man die hier eigentlich killen? Nee, oder?
Das ist, das ist scripted, egal
wie viel Damage man macht.
Das ist garantiert scripted, man kann die nicht killen.
Sonst würden die ganzen Speedrunner die hier killen
und irgendwie den Tritt nackt
überspringen.
Nee, das geht bestimmt nicht.
Bleibt immer bei 1 HP stehen.
Feels a Batman.
Das Gute ist halt,
wenn man schnell ist,
dann haben sich die
Maps noch nicht resetet
und man findet die Sachen einfacher.
So, okay, was muss ich
als nächstes machen? Ich muss jetzt diese
Statuen einsammeln.
Drei Stück.
Und dann raus
Marketplace.
Gleich haben wir das.
Ich glaube, ich bin falsch.
Ja.
Eine Statue ist...
Es sind immer zwei Statuen, glaube
vor dem Waypoint und eine nach dem
Waypoint.
Habe ich mal in irgendeinem Guide gelesen.
Oder auch nicht.
Dann war es eine davon, immer
zwei danach. Dann war es
umgedreht. Dann war es umgedreht.
Das ist auf jeden Fall immer gleich.
Sofern der Guide stimmt,
dann ist es immer
eine Statue vor dem
Waypoint und immer zwei nach dem
Waypoint.
Was übrigens auch noch eine Sache ist,
die mir echt gut an
Path of Exile gefällt.
Dadurch, dass das Game so wirr ist an vielen
Stellen. Ich meine, das ist ja an vielen
Stellen echt null intuitiv.
Bringt halt
so gewisses Game Knowledge voll was.
Aber ich kann
es verstehen, dass sie das mit Path of Exile 2
ein bisschen zugänglicher machen wollen.
Ja, du hast ja, ich glaube in Path of Exile 2
kriegen die Leute ja dann
beispielsweise auch Six Links auf
Billig-Items
zum besseren Einstieg und so.
Wobei, später wirst du eh noch selbst linken müssen.
Es ist, also
Path of Exile ist schon sehr viel
so mystisch
irgendwie. Du weißt nicht genau, was
passiert, aber
es gibt dann irgendwelche Guides und irgendwelche
Sachen, Leute, die was Data Mind
haben und dann
irgendwie eine App oder eine Webseite
erstellt haben, die dir die Wahrscheinlichkeit
ausrechnet für irgendwas. Also da
ist schon sehr viel
Magic bei Path of Exile
dabei. So, Leute.
Zwei Level noch. Zwei Level.
Dann haben wir den Bogenstelz hinter uns.
Aber so wirklich,
so wirklich gut geht es erst im nächsten
Akt dann.
Mit Crater
mit, wie heißt das
Ding auf Deutsch?
Größere Projektile.
Keine Ahnung. Multiple
Projectiles.
Crater Multiple
Projectiles. Größere,
mehrere größere
Projektile.
Excellent.
Ich weiß schon, warum ich so Dinger nie auf
Deutsch spiele.
By the way, wir haben uns doch letztens die Xbox-Präsentation
angeguckt, ne?
Die Halo-Demo war auf dem PC.
Man hat irgendwie gedacht,
sie wäre auf der Xbox, aber she baited.
Ich wollte kurz Licht anmachen, aber
she baited. Die Halo-Demo war
auf dem PC.
War aber auch irgendwo klar.
Hätte mich gewundert.
Wenn sie da nicht
irgendwie ein bisschen getrickst hätten.
Skillpoints in
Catacombs nicht vergessen.
Was, in Catacombs gibt es Skillpoints?
Ne, in Catacombs
gibt es Respecs, oder?
In Catacombs gibt es ein Lab und ein Respec.
Ja, irgendwie so.
Genau.
Ne, Lab habe ich schon.
Ich muss jetzt Battlefront oder Warfront
oder wie das heißt raus.
Die Guards killen und dann
Solaris.
Den Typ bashen wir nochmal schnell.
Der macht mir zu viel
Damage.
Und droppt nix.
Weil ich auch überhaupt keine
Drops brauche.
Ah, nein.
Ich will
Warfront raus.
Irgendwo, wenn wir Glück haben, hier.
Für was
habe ich nicht genug Int?
Oder soll ich sagen, ich bin nicht Big Brain
genug, um Flamedash zu lernen?
Das glaube
ich aber nicht, ja.
Dann brauchen wir noch einen weiteren
Int-Point.
Und ich habe mich übrigens
voll verskillt, ne.
Muss hier gar nicht hin, sondern, sondern.
Muss.
Dahin.
Der hier ist
verskillt.
Aber ich werde es überleben.
Kann er einfach später Rückgänge machen.
Oder, ich meine im Prinzip,
ich specke eh komplett um, wenn ich 70 bin.
Oder 75.
Oder vielleicht mit 80. Vielleicht specke ich mit 80 erst um.
Specke mit 80 komplett um.
Wahrscheinlich, wahrscheinlich brauche ich
aber, ich brauche
bestimmt 30 Respec Points oder so.
Weil von dem Tree
auf
Cast on Crit
Dings. Ich sage immer, ich sage immer
Frost Nova, weil Diablo, aber es ist
Eis Nova.
Ganz anderer Skill Tree.
Aber besser angenehm leveln.
Anstatt sich da rum zu quälen.
Dann gäbe ich lieber ein bisschen was aus für Skill Points.
Yepcock, genau.
Was jetzt noch gut wäre
bei dem Spiel, wenn die es schaffen
würden,
dass mehr Leute
am Start bleiben. Ich meine, die
haben, ich kann, lass mich hier hoch springen,
ich meine, die haben mehr Spieler als
je zuvor im Endeffekt durch die ganzen Leaks.
Aber die Leaks,
die meisten Leute machen es halt wie ich.
Die spielen 1-2 Monate.
Oder die spielen so
bis zur Hälfte der League.
Hälfte, zwei Drittel der League.
Und dann haben sie keinen Bock mehr.
Es wäre cool, wenn sie noch irgendwie ein paar Mechaniken einbauen
würden, dass die Leute auch dranbleiben.
Was halt blöd ist, wenn du dann
Atlas halbwegs fertig hast und
eins bis
fünf gute Chars hast.
Was willst du
großartig machen, ja?
Gäbe es sicherlich noch ein paar Möglichkeiten,
da was,
da irgendwas zu drehen.
Zum Beispiel, was ich
mir überlegt habe,
was ich eigentlich für eine richtig geile
Idee halte.
Die Leute leveln ja
massig Charaktere.
In so einer League.
Also, wenn man sich manche Streamer anguckt
und manche Leute, die haben irgendwie gefühlt 10-15 Charaktere
am Ende oder so.
Und...
Man könnte es so machen,
dass man,
weil es kann sein, dass es kompletter Schwachsinn ist,
aber klingt für mich erstmal ganz nice,
dass man
quasi so ein
dass es irgendwie so ein extra
Punktesystem gibt, wo man
sich dann halt irgendwelche Sachen für
craften, gearen, was auch immer
kann. Also, es ist egal, was man damit
macht, wo man quasi
sagen wir mal, einen 80 plus Charakter
opfern kann.
Und...
Dafür kriegt man dann irgendwelche
Currency Items oder so,
mit denen man was machen kann.
Dann hat es nämlich auch Sinn,
einfach Charaktere zu leveln.
Ähm...
Und wenn man sie nicht mehr spielen will, kann man
sie einfach opfern, kriegt Currency für.
Es müsste aber irgendwas spezielles sein.
Keine normale Currency,
irgendwas eigenes.
Paradies für Botter, ist doch egal,
ist das Spiel eh schon.
Brain Freeze, abonniert Twitch Prime, dankeschön.
Excellent Subscription.
Massive.
Ja. Big.
Oh, Moment, ich muss ihn erstmal killen.
Ja.
Big Brain Subscription, dankeschön.
Extrem sinnvolle Tür.
Äh, 8 Stunden Chill-Steps
Playlist. Morpheus, ich kann dir gar nicht sagen, was es ist.
Erste Playlist, genau.
Wo geht's runter?
Da geht's runter.
Excellent.
So. Danach machen wir Docks.
Und wenn wir Docks fertig haben,
rüsten wir auch Spellslinger um.
Perfekt.
So werden wir es machen.
Weil ich merke schon, dass
dieser Pfeilstelzen immer lange gut geht.
Mal überlegen, was wir dann für Spellslinger
brauchen, aber wir müssen eigentlich
alles da haben.
Essence Train haben wir glaube
mitgenommen von irgendeiner Quest.
Oder können es kaufen.
Contagions haben wir.
Soulrend haben wir glaube auch.
Äh, Spellslinger
kann man kaufen in Act 3.
Also wir müssten
mehr oder weniger alles haben.
Wenn nicht, muss ich noch ein paar Gems kaufen.
Es könnte sein, dass ich die Library-Quests
noch machen muss, je nachdem, was ich brauche.
Ob ich da überhaupt keinen Bock drauf habe, ehrlich
gesagt.
Welche Leak-Mechanik ist deine liebste?
Naja, wie gesagt, den Account
gibt es zwar seit 2013,
aber so richtig angefangen habe ich erst mit
Metamorph wieder.
Also ich kann zu den ganzen Leak-Mechaniken nicht viel sagen.
Also ich meine, ich kenne sie halt,
die übrig gebliebenen, die hier drinnen sind.
Also Breach finde ich ultra nice.
Einfach, weil ich auf Monster-Bashen stehe.
Wann ist eigentlich der C++-Stream?
Äh...
Also...
Breach...
fand ich sehr nice.
Und...
Ich finde die aktuelle auch cool.
Nämlich aus einem Grund.
Ich mag das Craften überhaupt nicht.
Ich bash lieber irgendwelche Monsters.
Aber es gibt mehr
High-End-Items.
Und man kann die Seeds einfach verkaufen.
Sobald das andere macht.
Und durch das Seed-Sellen
kann man halt massive Kohle machen.
Delph bin ich noch
nie so richtig reingekommen.
Delph bin ich noch nie so richtig reingekommen.
Ich hab immer mal ein paar Level gemacht.
Kobold-Stream.
Den Kobold-Stream machen wir bald.
Ich hab mich ja schon drauf eingestellt,
dass ich hier mal wieder Kobold streamen muss.
Oder mal wieder. Was heißt mal wieder?
Dass ich jetzt demnächst endlich mal Kobold streamen muss.
So rum.
Das wird aber ätzend.
Also es gibt kaum was schlimmeres,
als Kobold zu streamen.
Also Kobold zu programmieren und den Kram
auch noch streamen zu müssen, ist ja wirklich...
fast schon...
Folter.
Also wenn die noch irgendwelche...
Ich fungier da gerne als Berater,
Wenn die noch irgendwelche Folter-Methoden suchen,
wo man es den Leuten danach nicht ansieht,
dass sie gefoltert wurden,
dann sollten wir es mal mit Kobold probieren.
Da kannst du Waterboarding
und alles mögliche einpacken.
Einfach 5h Kobolden, der erzählt dir alles.
Sterben please.
Sterben please. Mob. Mob.
Da kann ich mich noch in der Beta dran erinnern.
In der Beta war es ja auch so, dass das Spiel drei Schwierigkeitsgrade hatte, was jetzt ja nicht mehr so ist.
Jetzt ist ja eine durchgängige Kampagne.
Du hattest ja quasi nur die ersten drei Acts und halt dann wie in Diablo quasi normal, cruel, merciless, was glaube ich in PoE.
Und in Docks hat man sich damals Level geboostet as fuck.
Du bist einfach durch den kompletten Act gerannt, nur um Docks zu gehen und Power zu leveln.
Sag mal, kann ich das Ding jetzt mal finden?
Wenn ich das hier durch hab, kommt Spellslinger-Setup ran.
Dann kommt eigentlich dieser Bogenmüll weg, ey.
Wow, was ist das?
Was kommt da an, Gewirbelwinde?
Ah!
Piss dich alle.
Aha.
Hier heben wir mal auf.
Ah, da unten ist es.
Pass auf, jetzt ist es Fairgraves.
Nein, das ist das Richtige.
Sehr gut.
Jawoll.
So.
Kommen wir nehmen mal nach Portal-Scroll.
Lunaris 2.
Abgeben.
Und dann neue Gems.
Ja.
Achso, ich wollte die Gems.
Ah ja.
Das wird es auch noch kurz tun.
Vielleicht.
Warte ich doch bis 31, dann kann ich mehr Gems reinpacken.
Ja, ich warte bis 31.
Bis 31 ist besser.
Ich warte bis 31, dann kann ich noch mehr Gems reinmachen.
Ist ja schnell gelevelt hier.
Guck mal, wir sind jetzt quasi schon 29.
Dauert 5 Minuten.
Zieh es in einem durch.
Ich würde gerne,
aber dafür habe ich zu spät angefangen zu streamen.
Ich würde es gerne am Stück machen,
das ich hinter mir habe.
Aber es ist mir, glaube ich, zu lang.
Dann müsste ich
bis zur Nacht um 4 Uhr oder so streamen.
Auf geht's.
Der ist kacke, an dem verrecke ich immer.
An dem Dude verrecke ich immer.
Ah, nice.
Das geht ja durch sein Energy Shield.
Okay, vielleicht verrecke ich doch nicht.
Der kann ja gar nichts.
Außer diese komischen Feuerbälle.
Oh.
Komm, verrecken, please.
Easy.
AF.
Um nicht zu sagen,
Ja, 29, 2 Level warten wir noch.
Dann kann ich mir Gems equippen.
Du bist dabei, musst selber griden.
Fuck, Alter.
Mal gucken, wie lange ich mache.
Also den Akt machen wir auf jeden Fall noch fertig.
Und ich würde ja auch gerne den nächsten Akt noch machen.
Mal gucken, wie lange.
Vielleicht machen wir auch komplett.
Morgen auf.
Stimmt.
Nee, wenn ich morgen aufwache, Stream machen will,
dann kann ich nicht bis zur Nacht um 4 Uhr spielen.
Soll das gehen?
Aber es ist auch wieder eine wahnsinnig sinnvolle Tür hier.
Sag mal, kann das sein, dass der Lonares-Tempel Stufe 1
immer das gleiche Layout hat?
Mir kommt das so bekannt vor.
Ja, das sieht immer gleich aus irgendwie.
Oder es gibt nur zwei Layouts.
Kann auch sein.
Nee.
Okay, das letzte Mal ging es, glaube ich, links lang.
Und jetzt nicht.
Nee, dann sieht es bloß so aus.
Nee, nee, dann sieht es echt nur so aus.
Dann gibt es doch mehr.
Gute Layouts.
Äh, was skillen wir jetzt eigentlich?
Hier habe ich mich verskillt.
Jetzt kommt das.
Dann kommt die Chaos-Notes.
Ein Respec brauche ich noch.
Aber kriege ich später in den nächsten.
In den späteren Akten gibt es ja Respec.
Und soll ich in einer Quest...
Oh.
Nee, nee.
Dich lasse ich da einfach mal stehen.
In der Kampagne hat doch alles das gleiche Layout.
Nee.
Das Spiel ist komplett randomized.
Jeder Durchgang.
Oder was heißt jeder Durchgang?
Jedes Map-Betreten nach 10 Minuten ist randomized.
Bis auf ganz wenige Ausnahmen.
Manche Maps sind gleich.
Ich glaube, das Badehaus ist immer gleich.
Und ein paar andere Sachen.
Aber 90% des Spiels ist komplett randomized.
Oh, ich fürchte, wir müssen Piety noch killen mit diesem komischen Bogensetup.
Buh.
Ah.
Hm.
Und das ist eines der nervigsten Gebiete im ganzen Spiel.
Da gibt es hier nämlich diese komischen...
Genau die hier.
Die sind ultra nervig und machen Damage as fuck.
Diese komischen...
Weiß nicht, was das ist da.
Tentakel-Monster.
Aber dann nur minimal.
Nee.
Die Maps sind teilweise komplett unterschiedlich.
Wie gesagt, das letzte Mal ging es bei mir hier in Lunaris 2 nach oben weiter, anstatt nach unten.
Alter, die Tentakel...
Tentakel-Monster hier.
Wäre der Sibaro mal hier.
Dem wird das gefallen.
Kappa HD.
Ah.
Okay, ein Level noch.
Ja, das...
Ja, das stimmt.
Da hat...
Ähm...
Cypher Dark.
Da blicke ich aber auch noch zu 100% durch.
Ich hab das...
Oh nee, hier geht es gar nicht weiter.
Ich hab das jetzt in ein paar Speedruns gesehen.
Die erkennen extrem...
Also wirklich extrem gut.
Wo ich mich frage, wie kriegen sie das hin.
Wie die Maps verlaufen.
Wie gesagt.
Manchmal spawnt irgendwas schräg und daran erkennt er sofort, ah, hier geht es weiter und sowas.
Also richtig...
Da brauchst du richtig krass Game-Knowledge.
Lunaris aus Arc 7.
Lunaris aus Arc 7 hat doch gar keine...
Ist da nicht alles im ersten Stockwerk?
Ah, nee.
Oh, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow.
Ist ja gut hier.
Tentakel-Viecher.
Ist ja mal gut.
Machen aber auch Damage.
Welches Backend-Framework...
Würdest du empfehlen?
Bin auch in der Ausbildung und programmiere hauptsächlich mit C++ Qt.
Backend-Framework für Web.
Oder?
Vermute ich jetzt mal.
Also für was sonst.
Ähm...
Ja, bei C++ kann ich dir da leider nichts Gutes zu raten.
Ich bin ja absolut kein C++-Fan.
Also ich könnte den ganzen Tag einen Stream machen, wo ich C++ flame.
CUTE ist eines der wenigen guten Sachen aus der C++-Welt.
Leider ist es C++.
Aber in C++ kann ich dir wirklich kein Gutes...
Kenn ich mich nicht aus.
Außerdem würde ich Anfälle kriegen, wenn ich noch mehr C++ machen müsste als notwendige.
Oder darf es auch was anderes als für C++ sein?
Dann kann ich dir mehr raten, ja.
Aber ein Backend-Framework für C++ kann ich dir leider nichts zu sagen.
Ich bin noch nie auf die Idee gekommen, eine Web-Anwendung mit C++ Backend zu machen.
Und ich hoffe, die Idee braucht auch noch eine Weile, bis ich da drauf komme.
Moment, hier war ich schon.
Warum laufe ich denn wieder zurück?
Kack-Noob.
Also wenn es was anderes als C++ sein darf, dann...
Da sind ja sehr viele Möglichkeiten.
Also meine persönliche Lieblingskombination...
...kombination ist ja .NET Core, C Sharp, Entity Framework...
...ASP.NET Core, also im Prinzip ASP.NET Core mit C Sharp.
Und JavaScript Vue.js Frontend.
Das ist so meine Lieblingskombi.
Auch finde ich auch sehr einsteigerfreundlich.
ASP.NET ist eigentlich ganz nett.
Hier gibt es auch sehr viele Tutorials zu.
GTK, Moment, es geht um Web-Backend.
Frameworks für Web-Backends.
Da ist GTK jetzt nur...
...wirklich nicht das Richtige für.
So, ich glaube, wir sind hier gleich durch.
Ja.
Okay, ein Level noch.
Die bashe ich noch, die Viecher hier.
Bin ich 31?
Oh ne, jetzt gibt es hier nichts mehr, oder was?
Oh Gott.
Ich wollte es auch bis 31 machen.
Äh...
Trainness?
Nope.
Ich bin ja selbst da nicht der große Pro, was das angeht, ne?
Bin noch am Lernen.
Aber vielleicht haben wir welche im Chat, die sich gut auskennen.
Also, ich will einfach nur 31 noch.
Ob...
Ach, vielleicht mit den Viechern hier.
Möchte ich mich nicht verskinenchen.
Du kannst ja re-specken.
I- I- Klar, es kostet bissl was.
Aber du kannst ja re-specken.
Also ich werde es hier auch machen.
Ich level hier mit diesem Bogengestellsetz bis 31.
Dann switch ich auf Chaos Spellslinger und dann...
... re-specke ich, quasi, so ab 75 oder 70, re-specke ich noch mal komplett...
auf gas und griff eisenhofer das kostet wahrscheinlich schon so 30 respect
points oder sowas aber du bekommst 18 respect points in der kampagne gut ich
meine ich war vielleicht erzähle ich dir aus zeug was du was du schon alles
weiß ja kann ja auch sein ich glaube du kriegst 18 respect points in der
kampagne what the fuck kann sich mal verpissen
ja das ist das ding macht der match und die respect ob sind jetzt auch nicht so
teuer zumal manche skill skill und einfach viel angenehmer sind zum leveln
derben plis ja das macht mir kein damage party da kannst du mal was willst du
sehen ach da das macht mir kein der mensch bei
der ganz werden das einzige was mir der mensch macht sie
die mähler angriffe und diese komischen pfeile da
damit kannst du mir nicht sch Eddy es aber echt nett sie macht ja nur
dieses mähler ding lol d с is da leva donna maccamp ja wir setze und 31 da
super so dann machen wir jetzt noch ein 0,1 level und dann hating irgendwo ist
vollkommen egal okay bis leather
Okay, das stimmt schon. Einfach drauf losbecken ist in Path of Exile nicht so sinnvoll.
Hast du Path of Building installiert?
Trainers?
Also Path of Building ist dieses Tool hier, wo man sich Skills angucken kann.
Exzellent.
So, also was brauchen wir denn jetzt für Skills?
So, also wir brauchen Spellslinger. Brauchen wir erstmal.
Drei Mal Spellslinger?
Ne, bei der nicht. Quatsch.
Erstmal den ganzen Crab abholen.
So, haben wir hier irgendwas, was wir noch brauchen?
Was können wir gebrauchen?
Low Class Ball Lightning.
Ne, alles Müll brauchen wir, alles nicht.
Soulrent, Soulrent brauchen wir.
Okay, dann muss ich den ganzen Kram mal in meiner Kiste ordnen.
Also, wir brauchen jetzt...
Wir brauchen Soulrent, wir brauchen...
Also den ganzen Müll kann ich schon mal wegschmeißen, das kommt jetzt fort.
Das brauchen wir jetzt, nichts davon brauchen wir mehr, außer Flamendash.
Flamendash behalten wir noch.
So, wir brauchen Spellslinger, haben wir auch schon mal.
Ah, ne, Moment.
Ha, das sind, das ist ja, das sind die anderen Gems von meinem Mool, von meinem letzten Schar.
Also, wir brauchen, okay, Flamendash, Soulrent.
Und wir brauchen...
Drei Mal Spellslinger.
Spellslinger, drei Mal Spellslinger, brauchen wir...
Äh, irgendwie sieht das fast gleich aus, ne?
Ach so, äh, ja, wenn das nur Endgame zeigt, dann schwierig, ja.
Aber auf der anderen Seite, durch die Kampagne kommst du eigentlich fast immer irgendwie durch.
In der Kampagne ist eigentlich das Einzige, worauf man achten muss, dass man genug Resis hat.
Wenn man genug Resis hat, ist alles gut.
Okay.
Okay, Spellslinger, Soulrent, Spellslinger, Spellslinger, dann brauchen wir hier noch Cont...
Contagion?
Bisschen auseinanderrücken.
Contagion.
Essence Train?
Spellslinger, Essence Train, Spellslinger, Contagion, Spellslinger, Soulrent.
Gut.
Das brauchen wir...
Oh, ich brauch noch ne Wand.
Kommt weg.
Hier noch Dash.
Ich brauch eine Wand.
Und...
Wer verkauft...
Ja, Stäbe.
Äh.
Und wer von den verkauft mir Zeugs?
Oh, irgendeine Wand mit vier Sockeln.
Kann ja nicht so schwierig sein.
Äh, mit drei Sockeln.
Ja.
Irgendwie sowas da.
Ah.
Perfekt.
Ah, ne, hier, guck mal.
Den, den haben wir.
Gut, perfekt.
Zack, weg damit.
Links, einmal linken.
Irgendwas.
Guck mal her.
Ah.
Weg damit.
So.
Ähm, was hab ich...
So, das...
Da kommt jetzt rein.
Jetzt muss ich gucken, da ich kein Mist-Skille,
ob ich keine Mist-Gems ausrüste.
Da kommt rein...
Spellslinger...
Muss mal kurz nachgucken.
Äh, Skills.
Also,
Essence-Train-Spellslinger.
Gut, das krieg ich erst später.
Und das krieg ich auch erst später.
Soul-Rant-Creator.
Das krieg ich auch erst später.
Frenzy.
Frenzy brauch ich.
Genau.
Increased Area krieg ich, glaub, auch später.
Wann kriegt man Increased Area?
Ach, das ist 38.
Okay, das krieg ich auch später.
Dann lassen wir das...
Dann lassen wir Increased Area erst mal...
Wow.
Okay, das...
Curse und Hit krieg ich auch noch nicht.
Das ist auch später.
Faster Attacks.
Okay, also...
Frenzy und Faster Attacks brauchen wir jetzt.
Wo gibt's Frenzy?
Wo kann man Frenzy kaufen?
Okay, Frenzy...
gibt es in...
Akt 2.
Moin, Kreen-X.
Okay, hier brauchen wir...
Frenzy.
Zack, und...
Controlled...
Controlled Destruction.
Ich glaub, brauchen wir 2.
Ganz sicher.
Faster Attacks.
Frenzy.
Ähm...
So, Controlled Destruction.
Ich glaub, jetzt hab ich alles.
Also, wir brauchen...
Der Rest ist eh 38.
Frenzy haben wir.
Hier, Faster Attacks.
Curse und Hit gibt's erst später.
Essence Train.
Controlled Destruction.
Okay, machen wir das mal hier.
Essence Train.
Spellslinger.
Und dann haben wir Spellslinger.
Soul Rend.
Haben wir auch noch nicht.
Creator Multiple Projectiles haben wir auch gemacht.
Später.
Efficacy.
Wo gibt's denn Efficacy?
Let's do it.
Okay.
Wo gibt's das?
Library Quests.
Okay.
Geh mal fort.
Gut.
Ähm...
Ja, sind wir fertig.
Sind wir erstmal equipped, wenn ich jetzt nix vergessen hab.
Soul Train haben wir.
Wollen wir's doppel checken hier.
Essence Train.
Soul Rants.
Spellslinger haben wir in der Chest.
Frenzy und Fast Attacks haben wir
in den Schuhen drin. Contagion
Spellslinger haben wir in der Chest.
Ja, passt doch alles.
Gut. Okay.
Mal gucken, ob das was taugt
jetzt. Ich hab keinen Bock
die Library-Quest zu machen. Wo ist denn die Library eigentlich?
Die ist Garden, glaube ich.
Da kommen wir jetzt direkt vorbei.
Vielleicht machen wir das doch schnell.
Ja.
Das könnte ich machen.
Das könnte ich machen, die Gems kaufen.
Aber
stimmt. Eigentlich ist es egal.
Hast recht.
Könnte ich machen, aber ich wollte eigentlich
erstmal gucken,
dass ich
quasi, wie ich zurechtkommen würde, wenn das
jetzt eine neue League wäre. Aber das ist bescheuert. Ich meine, ich laufe
mit einem Tabula Rasa,
eine irgendwie Goldrim und irgendwie
Movement Speed Boots rum. Also
hat es damit eh nichts zu tun. Da kann ich die auch gleich
kaufen gehen. Da hast du eigentlich recht.
Okay.
Efficiency, oder wie heißt das?
Effic-
Efficacy Support.
So, dann brauchen wir noch was.
Control Destruction haben wir.
Efficacy brauchen wir zweimal.
So.
Haben wir jetzt auch keine komische Library-Quest, man.
Oh, Crynex, das ist bitter.
Curse on Hit, Despair.
haben wir. Haben wir noch curse on hit. Purse on hit. Purse on hit. Äh, was hab ich ne eben gelöscht?
Ich kack noob. Äh, kann ich den Kram irgendwie rückgängig machen? Don't save. Building. Äh, nein, das ist
Cast on Crit. Irgendwie was. Das ist was anderes. Äh, Level. Wo hab ich das nochmal hergehabt hier?
Das Build zum Leveln. Ja. Blablabla. So, und jetzt Import. Import von Pastebin. Zack.
So, also was hab ich hier fürs... Skills vorhin gelöscht. Curse on hit. Faster Attacks.
Increase.
Increased Area. Aha. Increased Area. Gott, jetzt haben wir alles, ne? Jetzt haben wir alles.
Jupp. Ah, Crater Multiple Projector. Das brauchen wir noch. Excellent. Crater. Jawoll.
Kommen wir zweimal. Ich weiß nicht, ob wir es nicht zweimal brauchen. Haben wir alles.
Ich meine, der andere Kram ist zwar 38, aber das macht nix. Dann hab ich's mir nix.
Ich weiß nicht, ob wir es nicht zweimal brauchen. Dann hab ich's mir nix.
Dann hab ich's mir nix.
Dann hab ich's wenigsten schon.
Moment.
Ah!
No Competition.
Hab ich eins zu wenig.
Kann das sein?
Worin soll das noch rein?
Bei Essence Train.
Da muss noch...
Okay, ich brauch noch ein 4-Link.
Ähm...
Ich hab irgendwo noch was.
Ich hab hier in meiner super aufgeräumten Kiste
garantiert...
Garantiert...
Ach nee!
Ich bin doch doof.
Guck mal.
Wir können es doch ganz anders machen.
Ich kann das doch einfach das da rein machen.
Äh.
Ne.
Moment.
Ich bin verwirrt.
Äh.
Welslinger.
Saurant.
Schussi.
Das da.
Ja.
Echse.
Ah.
Verwirrung pur.
So.
Irgendein Schild könnten wir jetzt noch gleich suchen.
Aber passt.
Okay.
Zack, zack.
Ähm.
Frenzy.
Auf rechts klick.
Das weg.
Und auf W.
Ach ne.
Wo ist mein Flamedash?
Flame.
Flamedash.
Contagion.
Kommt Q.
Okay.
Wir haben es geschafft.
Oh.
Schwere Geburt.
Äh.
Oh Mist.
Jetzt muss ich da nochmal rauslaufen, weil ich den Waypoint nicht hab.
Aber 3200 Fusings ist hart.
So.
Okay.
Guck mal.
Guck mal, ob wir das jetzt schon...
Wenigstens was killen.
Okay.
Wir müssen irgendwie wieder...
Wir müssen den Ausgang finden.
Äh.
Ja.
Fällt...
Fällt doch etwas schneller um.
Wo ist der Ausgang?
Please.
Lass mich raus.
Hab den Waypoint nicht genommen.
Ja.
Die fallen doch etwas schneller um jetzt.
Sind Unique Items immer rares?
Nein.
Eher umgedreht.
In der Regel sind rares besser.
Es gibt ein paar Ausnahmen.
Da sind Unique Items immer rares besser.
Da sind Unique Items quasi erforderlich,
dass ein Build funktioniert.
Zum Beispiel, äh.
Wenn du Lowlife spielen willst,
gibt's, äh.
Dings, wie heißt's?
Schäffrons Rappings oder so ähnlich.
Brauchst du.
Oder auch, wenn du Sachen willst,
wo die Gegner explodieren.
Mit Schock.
Dann brauchst du Impulser.
Gibt andere Rare-Varianten, ja.
Aber manche Sachen gehen nur mit Uniques.
Aber in der Regel ist...
sind rares besser.
Ja.
Aber manche Sachen gehen nur mit Uniques.
Jetzt verkommmer, wie schnell die umfallen.
Und ich hab noch nicht mal ansatzweise hier, äh.
Nicht mal ansatzweise gutes Gear
und noch nicht mal alle Gems drinne.
Lass mich raus.
Ich will doch nur den Ausgang finden.
Da.
Jetzt raus.
Also es gibt genug Leute.
Ich würd sogar mal sagen,
die meisten der quasi so High-End-Gear-Spieler,
die haben so gut wie keine Uniques.
Ich will nicht sagen gar keine,
aber so gut wie keine Uniques drin.
In ihrem Endgame-Gear.
Ja, Headhunter, okay.
Ich mach den Dude wieder da.
Der, der, der war doch schon down.
Ich bin richtig dumm.
Ich hab, warum hab ich den Waypoint hier nicht genommen?
Das ist eigentlich mega hängen geblieben, ne?
Der Waypoint ist der offensichtlichste von allen.
Ich hab ihn nicht gecrapped.
Weil hier oben geht's jetzt weiter.
Boah, die fallen jetzt aber schon ganz gut um, die Geishners.
Weil ich mir auch nicht sicher bin,
ob nicht,
wenn du wirklich gutes Endgame-Setup an,
also an Build und, und Items hast,
ob du nicht lieber einen anderen Build als Headhunter spielst.
Keine Ahnung, also gibt bestimmt Builds,
da ist das nicht so der Wahnsinn, was anderes besser.
Zumal die meisten Leute nie in ihrer League
und an Headhunter kommen werden.
Ich hab letztens einen Clip gesehen von einem,
der war irgendwie halb AFK,
auf irgendeiner Map
und geht dann mit der Maus,
Zeiger über ein Item und irgendwie stellt fest,
Headhunter getroppt.
Nimmt es halt ohne irgendwie die Mine zu verziehen zur Kenntnis.
So, oh, Headhunter.
Ah, ich muss den Kram.
Guck mal, das sind alles Level 1 Gems gewesen.
Die Dinger fallen um wie nix.
Oh, ich hasse diese Dinger.
Die sprengen halt immer in die Luft.
Physical Damage stacheln.
Hier müsste jetzt der Waypoint gleich kommen.
Ey, please verrecken.
Hahaha.
Pff, alle einer.
We will be best friends, Beast.
Ah.
Gebaite mich doch nicht immer so, Map.
Kein Gebait.
Ja, schon wieder gebaited.
Hier ist das Lab.
Hier will ich gar nicht hin.
Ah.
You got gebaited.
Ich glaub, die Map ist nicht randomized
oder wenig randomized.
Ich glaub, ich hätte rechts laufen müssen hier.
Immer über die Hauptstraße.
Das wusste ich nicht.
Es gibt ja so ein paar Sachen, die in die, den einen Bandit an der Brücke findet man auch immer über die Straße.
Excellent.
So, äh, sind wir dann stehen geblieben?
Sind wir dann stehen geblieben?
Free?
Wir können uns hier, wir holen uns hier unten noch, ach nee, das machen wir später.
Äh, was haben wir denn?
Chaos Damage, Chaos Damage, Stings, Strength.
Area, Area ist nicht schlecht.
Wir gehen live.
Ja, wir holen noch ein bisschen live.
Live kann man nicht genug haben.
Ah, übrigens, einen Respec brauche ich da noch.
Äh, genau.
Nämlich den da.
Hab ich verskillt.
Null.
Übrigens, wenn man Control gedrückt hält, kann man, äh, Instance backen.
Guckt hier so.
Bam.
Ohne bestätigen zu müssen.
Machen die ganzen Ultra-Speedrunner-Dudes.
Und was auch noch geiler Trick ist, was ich ja von irgendeinem Speedrun-Mensch abgeguckt hab.
Was ich nicht brauche.
Ich brauche aber was Cooles.
Ähm, man kann, wenn der hier tot ist, äh, man kann Movement.
Auf.
Sterben, please.
So.
Leute, ich will euch nur was zeigen.
Geht mal fort.
So.
Also, was man machen kann.
Man, ähm, kann, äh, Leertaste.
Man kann Leertaste auf, äh, keine Ahnung, Skill.
Skill.
Use, äh, irgendwie den da legen.
Was?
One or more action is not set.
Äh, close all user interface.
Escape.
Äh.
Was weiß ich?
Minus.
Ist mir doch egal.
Save.
So.
Ähm.
Und.
Dann kann man Movement da drauf legen.
Und dann kann man quasi mit der Leertaste laufen, während man in den Menüs rumklickt.
Also, ich klick jetzt nicht.
Also, ich bin jetzt hier im Inf und klick rum.
Und mit der Leertaste kann man laufen.
Ich bin im Inf und wenn ich, naja, jetzt hier ist es doof, aber, im Inventar und mit Leertaste
kann man laufen.
Das hab ich mir so von so einem Speedrun-Mensch abgeguckt, ähm, weil die, die switchen immer
ihre Gems, während sie quasi mit Leertaste laufen.
Das geht, ja, das geht im, im Tree, wenn du den Tree aufhast, geht.
Guckt.
Also, wenn du weißt, wo du hinlaufen musst, kannst du skillen, skillen und laufen dabei.
Was man kann mit Num-Skills nutzen, ohne sie zu drücken und das legal.
Hä?
Wie?
Verstehe nicht.
Was meinste?
Wie, ohne sie zu drücken?
Num musst du doch auch drücken.
So, ich will jetzt noch schnell durch den Akt hier durch.
Sonst wird das mit morgen, morgen früh Aufwach-Stream nix, ja.
Volle Pulle.
Speedrun-Mode.
Oh, das geht deutlich angenehmer, als diese komische Bogenstelz-Geschichte vorher.
Was setzt Skill auf einen Ziffernblock und während der an ist, einfach Num ausmachen?
Ja, und dann geht der Skill weiter, ohne dass du was drückst.
Ach, so Autocast quasi.
Das meine ich so in Passive Excel.
Also, Game-Knowledge ist richtig huge, wenn man sich da auskennt.
Autocast.
Übrigens, bei dem Boss verrecke ich immer, weil ich nicht weiß, was ich machen muss,
wenn er sein AE macht.
Ansonsten ist der Boss easy.
Hallo, Tür.
Ich habe aber übelst krasses RNG-Glück, oder?
Wie ich hier durchkomme gerade.
Map-Hack.
Omega-Ludel.
Übrigens, mal eine Frage an euch, Chat.
Wenn ihr ins Bett geht schlafen, habt ihr dann irgendwas laufen im Hintergrund, oder
habt ihr am liebsten Totenstille, so?
Totenstille.
Podcasts, okay.
Manchmal YouTube-Vans.
Ja, ja gut.
Wenn schon YouTube, dann mit YouTube-Vans, wenn es Android ist.
Stille.
Ja, ich...
Bei mir ist es mittlerweile anders.
Also, früher konnte es mir nicht leise genug sein.
Aber irgendwie seit ein paar Jahren, so drei, vier Jahren.
Oh, nicht ganz, aber zwei, drei Jahren.
Habe ich angefangen irgendwelche Streams zu gucken auf dem Smartphone auf Twitch.
Bevor ich ins Bett bin.
Da habe ich mich jetzt so daran gewöhnt, dass ich...
Gar nicht mehr richtig pennen kann, wenn nichts läuft.
Ist eigentlich schlecht, weil ich denke, man schläft schlechter, wenn was läuft.
Insgesamt.
Aber ich habe mich dann so daran gewöhnt, ich kann jetzt da kaum pennen ohne.
Deswegen mache ich es jetzt so.
Deswegen freue ich mich immer, wenn irgendwelche Speedrun-Marathons laufen, ja.
Und gerade läuft ja auch hier...
Das Ding.
Twitch.
Ja.
Aktuell läuft ja der Kram gerade.
Das kann man sich immer richtig gut im Hintergrund geben.
Wann ist Gamestown Quick? Gucke ich nicht mehr.
Die sind mir zu politisch korrekt mittlerweile.
Und weil bei solchen Speedrun-Events, da reißen sich die Leute immer ein bisschen im Rahmen.
Und schreien dich auf einmal random rum.
Wenn du dir manche Streams anguckst, da musst du Angst haben, dass du dich gleich des Todes erschreckst.
Weil irgendein Typ gerade ausflippt.
Und so Speedrun-Marathons gucke ich immer gerne.
Gut.
Bosskiller ist das Ding hier natürlich nicht, ne.
Aber für den Kram hier reicht es.
So.
Und vielleicht kennt sich irgendjemand von euch mit dem Boss aus.
Also bei Dominus checke ich nie, wie ich überlebe, wenn der seinen Regen-AE macht.
Äh.
Wo ist der Gegner?
Ach da.
Der macht irgendwann so ein Blutregen.
Blutregen-AE.
Und ich weiß nicht, wie ich da ausweiche.
Wenn du in der Blase bist, macht er...
Welche Blase?
Wow.
Jetzt habe ich auf den Chat geguckt.
Naja, ist ja gut.
Komisches Viech da.
Geh weg.
By the way, ich mag die Musik in dem Tempel nicht.
Wuuu.
Übelst.
Oh.
Monkeys.
F.
Ach, rein in die Glocke.
Okay.
What the fuck ist denn jetzt hier gerade los?
Können wir verrecken, please?
So.
Ups.
Die Attacke kenne ich.
Da bin ich schon mal dran verreckt.
Aber ich habe nicht aufgepasst.
Deswegen spiele ich übrigens Softcore.
Da kannst du auch mal sowas verkacken.
Gut, ich habe Resis.
Das passiert nicht.
Eigentlich sind die meisten Storybosse übelst easy as fuck.
So, ich muss jetzt mal gucken, was ihr meint.
Mit Blase.
weiß. Ich renne immer
vor allem weg, was an Bossen glänzt
und glüht.
Weil die meistens
Damage machen, wenn irgendwas glänzt und glüht.
Okay, das ist einfach, wenn man es
weiß.
Um nicht zu sagen, easy as fuck.
Einfach Facetank.
Aber ich...
Der macht mir zu viel Damage, oder?
Der kriegst du doch
gar nicht geheilt.
Echt? Okay.
Okay. Ach, cool.
Oh. Ach, nee.
Oh, gar nicht so schlecht.
Aha. Okay.
Ach, stimmt. Die hab ich ja
ganz vergessen.
So, ich muss nochmal kurz zurück.
Gucken,
ob ich alle Skillbücher abgeholt hab.
Wollte ich sagen, dass ich irgendwo was vergessen hab.
Nope.
Wann ist denn so der beste
Zeitpunkt,
das normale Lapp zu machen?
Nach dem nächsten Act?
Oder bei diesem Act?
Okay, ich hab alles abgeholt.
Macht dir Zoggen auch Spaß?
Ja.
Es fehlt einem das Richtige. Das ist das Problem.
Das war eines der besten Sachen,
die ich machen konnte, als ich wieder
Grindgame wie Pass of Exile
angefangen hab.
Ich glaub, ich mach das Lapp jetzt.
Ich geh in die Stadt, das Lapp mach ich noch.
Oder...
Nee, ich glaub, ich glaub, ich warte
bis 38, weil 38
hab ich dann alle Spells, die ich brauch.
Wir haben ja doch jetzt schon Blatt-Aqueducts,
da werden wir durch.
Eigentlich brauch ich das überhaupt nicht killen. Wozu?
Nee, der Boss ist wahrscheinlich
echt kein Problem.
Generell, wenn einen da nicht irgendwie
eine Falle doof erwischt,
ist das eigentlich allgemein.
Ist das...
...kein großartiges Problem.
Was brauch ich denn? 38, 38, 38...
Äh...
Dann machen wir doch noch hier weiter.
Machen wir noch die Kampagne weiter.
Zack, zack.
Ich bin ja froh,
dass ich mittlerweile zum größten Teil
die Kampagne auswendig kann.
Wenn ich permanent Guide gucken müsste,
dann wär's verrückt im Kopf.
Das hier ist
by the way ein super Gebiet,
um kurz neben... zwischendurch zu leveln.
Vielleicht ein Plus-Eins-Gam...
Ja?
Äh...
Hab ich, glaub ich, sogar irgendwo noch.
Gucken, was der Kram kostet.
Dürfte ja nicht die Welt kosten.
Ich bei...
Scheiß auf die anderen Stats, ne?
Guck ich gleich mal, was das kostet.
Das ist ne gute Idee.
Schneller zu kaufen, als dass ich den Kram
da in meiner Kiste gesucht hab.
Falls ich überhaupt eins hab.
Wir können ne Wand und ein Schild kaufen.
Ich mein...
Who cares?
Dafür hab ich genug Währung am Start.
Wo's halt richtig teuer wird,
ist dann die Kombination.
Plus All-Scale-Games und Chaos-Games.
Huge Boss.
Clear Potential hier.
Aber zum Glück sind die Kampagnenbosse
alle Easy-Mode.
Wow.
Warum ist der denn dahin?
Ich cleare oben nochmal kurz
den anderen Kampagnenboss.
Ich cleare oben nochmal kurz den anderen Kram.
Das gibt nämlich Instant-Level-Up.
Instant-Level-Up.
Na, gucken wir mal kurz auf der Trade-Seite.
Ich hab jetzt schon die ganze Zeit gesagt,
das ist das Letzte, was wir machen.
Aber irgendwie hab ich keinen Bock aufzuhören.
Das ist das, was ich bei Papesso Vexile im Vergleich zu Diablo 3 halt hab.
Ich hör nicht auf zu spielen.
Komm, level up, please.
Chaos-Multiplier krieg ich auch im Skill-Tree auf jeden Fall noch massig.
Klar, aber auf Equip schadet es natürlich auch nicht.
So, level up.
Level up.
Guck mal schnell auf der Trade-Seite.
P.O.E. Pogos.
Äh, Trade.
Also, wir suchen...
Oh, wie heißt das?
Chaos...
...Skill...
...Gems...
Okay, Moment, Moment, Moment.
Das ist aber echt...
What the fuck?
So viel wollte ich jetzt für ein Level-Item eigentlich nicht ausgeben.
Category...
...Want...
Moment.
Ich suche nach dem Falschen, oder?
Chaos-Spell-Gems muss ich suchen.
Ah!
Ich hab nämlich falsch gesucht.
Äh, das ist doch ganz gut.
doch ganz nett. Achso, Mid-Level. Oh lolololol. Moment. Max-Level. Aha, da kommen wir der Sache
schon näher. Ich bin 34. Ups, 34. Gibt es das auch noch mit Spell-Damage? Gibt es die Kombi?
Chaos-Multiplier. Ne, Chaos. Oh, wie heißt denn der Kram? Chaos-Increase-Overtime-Multiplier.
Ohohoho, da wird es teuer. Da wird es teuer. Ne, das machen wir nicht. Und auf einem
Schild gibt es das auch gar nicht zusammen. Ne. Wollen wir mal Shield. Das ist gar nicht übel.
Oh ja.
All-Elemental-Resistance. Das könnte doch ein bisschen mehr Spell-Damage haben vielleicht, ne?
Gucken wir mal, was es hier noch mit Spell-Damage gibt. Spell-Damage? Spell-Damage-Explicit. Hey,
das ist gut. Das ist gut. Hey, das ist gut. Wo ist mein Kist? Das ist gut. Andere Kram ist zu
teuer. Haben wir Glück? Das ist kein Kram. Das ist kein Kram. Das ist kein Kram. Das ist kein Kram.
Das ist kein Kram. Kein
Afk-Dude ist. Hi-Get. Lol. Hallo. Ah. Ah. Kann man das nicht? Lol. Passt Excellent.
Oh. Wo? Hat er mich gescamd? Wait a minute. Hat er mich gescamd? Hat er mich gescamd? Ah. Ne.
Moment. Ah, Autoequip. Habt ihr gesagt, er hat mich gescammt? Richtig das kann nicht Finger schналz haben.
Wait. Ist das das... WK presidente steht da? Sieht aus als Wow. Was geht da ein D favourit Queer-Papere- worries?
Und oder ja. So, das kann man nicht finden. Das tut nur gut, wenn man das ist, aber das делает einfach
Lul, ich hab schon gesagt, ich hab mich gescampt, Alter.
Auto-Equip, Alter, G-Bait.
So.
Das ist...
Ey, das Schild ist nicht übel, ja.
Okay, nice.
So, und jetzt noch eine Wand.
Jetzt noch eine Wand.
Lul.
Und...
Okay, da gibt's bestimmt nichts Neues jetzt.
Oh!
Das ist ja nice.
Das wollen wir haben.
Das ist bestimmt ein G-Bait-Angebot.
You got G-Baited.
Na komm, scheiß drauf.
Hab genug.
Oh, oh, nee, nee.
Easy.
Äh, äh.
Nice.
Haben wir richtig krasse Items für ein paar Chaos gekriegt.
Also was heißt richtig krasse, aber ziemlich gute Items.
So, dann werden wir das grad mal kurz, äh, färben.
Ist ja auch schon dreilängiger Color.
Ach, come on.
The big damage boost.
Ah, jetzt hier.
Poggers.
Huge boost.
So.
34, auf geht's weiter.
Nice.
Also ich finde, für den Preis kann man sich nicht beschweren, was wir da gekriegt haben.
Oh, man.
Ah.
Oh.
Also.
Ist schon okay.
Das ist jetzt kein OP, ist kein OP-Shit oder so, ne?
Ja, für zwei Chaos kannst du dir eh nicht beschweren.
Mit 38 geht's dann richtig ab.
Ich glaube, 38 mach ich noch.
Ich will sehen, wie das flutscht hier mit, äh, Projectiles.
Ich mein, das geht.
Guck mal hier, das macht übelste Damage jetzt schon.
Mit multiple Projectiles geht's noch mehr ab.
Das macht schon ganz gut.
Das macht schon ganz gut Damage jetzt, muss man sagen.
Äh, Max, wieso hast du das Spellslinger-Gam dreimal gekauft?
Äh, weil ich dreimal brauche.
Ich brauch's einmal in dem Setup hier.
Ich brauch's in dem Setup hier.
Und ich brauch's in, äh, dem Setup hier.
Also Spellslinger ist ja kein aktiver Skill.
Was Spellslinger macht, ist,
und das soll ich vielleicht mal kurz erklären,
Spellslinger nimmt die, äh, ähm, aktiven, oder nimmt die Skills, die mit ihm gelingt sind,
reserviert Mana dafür und bei jeder Attack, die man macht, mit seiner Waffe,
lösen dann automatisch die Spells aus, die mit Spellslinger gelingt sind.
Also ich caste die Spells nicht, ich klick eigentlich nur Attack.
Und dadurch, dass ich Attack klicke, löst Spellslinger, äh, einmal Soulrent aus,
einmal, äh, äh, Essence Drain aus und einmal Contagion aus.
Ja.
Und, äh,
umso weiter mein Spellslinger auflevelt,
umso mehr Damage konvertiert das von Physical, was die Waffe hat,
zu Magic,
was, äh, halt Spells haben.
Und deswegen hab ich dreimal drei Spellslinger gekauft.
Jetzt muss ich mal gucken, hier ist ja irgendwo noch so ein Mob,
so irgendein Viech, das man befreien muss für den Skillpoint.
Wo ist es denn?
Irgendwo ist ja noch so ein Viech, was man für den Skillpunkt befreien muss.
Dann eventuell noch Witchpure anstatt Manaflash.
Weiß ich gar nicht, was das macht, was macht das denn?
Weiß ich aus dem Kopf nicht.
Eins ist Despair-Kuss.
Äh, Despair hol ich mir gleich mit, äh, Casts.
Ja.
Kommt in die Schuhe oder, warte mal.
Äh, kommt in? Wo kommt es denn überhaupt rein?
Ähm.
Skills.
Ja, kommt in die Schuhe rein. Curse on Hit, Despair.
Sobald ich 38 bin.
Weiß ich, ob das da nicht ein bisschen doppelt gemoppelt ist.
Ach, da ist das Viech, ja.
Alles besser als eine Manaflash, da hast du recht.
Die Manaflash brauch ich wirklich nicht.
Aber ich hab immer ganz gern noch eine dabei, zumindest am Anfang, bis ich noch ein bisschen mehr Rack hab.
Aber ich brauch sie eigentlich nicht mehr.
Ich hab nicht recht, falls es doch mal ausgeht.
Aber das wird nicht ausgehen, das Mana.
Gerade mit Essence Train jetzt, wenn es noch besser wird.
Naja.
Eigentlich ums, eigentlich sinnlos, ja.
Stimmt schon.
Eigentlich sinnlos.
By the way, wie sieht der Stream bei euch aus mit, äh, ich hab 7900p eingestellt.
Das müsste eigentlich ziemlich gut aussehen.
Hallo?
Sterben, please.
7900k.
Nicht 7900p.
Naja, komm.
Linus hat letztens mit 8k gespielt.
Da kann ich auch mit 7900k spielen.
7900p.
Crispy clear.
Leider ist halt das Internet in Deutschland so kacke, ne?
Dass es eventuell ein paar gibt, wo der Stream ruckelt.
Deswegen.
Ne, 7900k.
Klingt fast wie ein Intel CPU.
Ist weniger.
Ne, Schwachsinn.
Keine Ahnung, was ich gerade von mir gebe.
Lol.
Oh.
Ergibt eigentlich keinen Sinn.
Ergibt eigentlich überhaupt...
What the...
Ergibt eigentlich überhaupt keinen Sinn, was ich gerade erzähle.
Ja, das ist schon richtig.
Habt ihr gut erkannt.
Oh, hier richtig Speedrun-Klicks.
Arnele geht ab.
Oh, heftig.
What?
Hä?
Map?
Ey, sag bloß.
Sag bloß.
Da oben rechts geht's lang.
MonkaS.
Wer soll das denn sehen?
Hallo, NA-Klick.
Da kippen sie um.
Flutscht richtig jetzt hier, seitdem wir auf Spellslinger umgestellt haben.
Aber das ist ja auch ziemliche Metaspeck zum Leveln gerade.
Ah, da sind wir.
Exquisite.
Ach, jetzt kommt das Zeug.
Genau.
Das ist eigentlich auch easy as fuck.
Ich bräuchte, ich bräuchte, ich bräuchte, äh, immer Pleat.
Pleat und Curse.
Immune of Flasks.
War's das?
Moment, was ist da gedroppt?
Crap.
Lull.
Brauch ich alles nicht.
Ich will mich nicht mehr dran erinnern, aber es gab ja am Anfang keine Lootfilter.
Das, der Bildschirm war voll mit, mit Crap-Items und du wusstest gar nicht, was du aufheben musstest.
Das Spiel hat am Anfang auch noch nicht mal sechs Links richtig angezeigt.
Du musstest jeden Müll...
Du musstest jeden Müll angucken, in der Hoffnung, äh, es ist da mal irgendwo ein, äh, kenn ich sechs Links, die sind sehr selten, ähm, sechs Sockels dabei und sowas, äh, so.
Exoil.
Kurz gucke, was das ist.
Lightning Cold?
Ah, ein bisschen merkwürdig.
Ah, das ist übel.
Attack Rate ist halt praktisch jetzt mit Spellslinger.
Ah, ne, jetzt funktioniert ja Autorun nicht.
Sixty-Nine Zuschauer.
Gachi-Bass.
Nice.
Wollen die mich rauslassen hier, please?
What?
Sag mal, geht's hier vielleicht...
What the hell?
Muss ich mir nicht alles killen, dass es weitergeht?
Kann ich mich überhaupt nicht mehr dran erinnern, dass das hier notwendig war?
Oder bin ich schlicht... Ich glaube, ich bin falsch gelaufen.
Hey, geht's nicht weiter.
Hier ist ja auch keine Tür oder sonst was.
Ne, falsche, falsche Richtung.
Los geht's.
Lol.
Debated.
Guck mal, die machen überhaupt kein Damage mehr.
Passiert mir laufend.
Ja.
Ich, äh, hatte ja eh immer Glück bisher.
Irgendwann war mir gar nicht so klar, dass man hier überhaupt
falsch laufen kann.
Ja.
Können wir das Gelaber gar nicht anhören.
Lore. Lol.
By the way, das Spiel hat übrigens eine Story.
Wer es noch nicht mitbekommen hat.
Aber eine ziemlich schlechte.
Hehehe.
Also ich glaube, Passive Exile ist echt ein Spiel,
da spielt niemand für die Story.
Man merkt auch richtig,
dass die vom Anfang an
keinen Plan hatten. Wow, wow, wow, wow.
Monka.
Keinen Plan hatten, was sie eigentlich
machen wollten.
Weil das passt doch überhaupt nicht zusammen.
Das ist ganz severe.
Also die Story ist wirklich nicht die Stärke
dieses Spiels.
Mal gucken, was sie in Passive Exile 2 machen.
Diesmal wissen sie ja ungefähr,
was auf sie zukommt.
Ich will ihnen mal nicht die Fähigkeit absprechen,
gescheite Storys zu schreiben.
Aber die Passive Exile Story ist nicht...
Oh, was war das?
Oh, Monka.
Jetzt ist ja mal gut.
Ah, guck mal.
Oh.
Exzellent.
Siehst du, da hat es sich auch gelohnt zu sterben.
Okay, inwieweit
sich das jetzt gelohnt hat. Ein Chaos, ob nicht.
Um mehr zu haben.
Bei, was weiß ich, 5000
oder so.
Ne, nicht ganz.
Macht es auch nicht fett.
What? Nein.
Ja, fertig.
Einfach mal durchs Town Portal
durchgeflitzt ist.
Spielst du VDS Belslinger
Necro? Ne.
Ich habe hier einen,
die liegt hier.
Wupp S.
Ne, das ist nur zum Leveln.
Das gibt Cast on Crit
Ice Nova.
Aber
ich level jetzt erst mal mit Chaos
Spellslinger.
Bis so, keine Ahnung,
70 oder so.
75.
Weil das einfach sich total easy
und schnell leveln lässt.
Und dann gebe ich lieber ein bisschen Geld aus
für Respec.
Guck mal, die Gegner können überhaupt nichts machen.
Die kriegen mega auf den Sack.
Einmal draufgecastet, down.
Wo hier? Die können ja nicht mal spawnen.
Da sind die schon tot.
Guck hier, zack.
Ui.
Warum hast du das nicht aufgepickt?
Regret sind immer...
Ja, ich habe erstens noch jede Menge.
Und
ja, du hast schon recht, man kann sich auch easy kaufen.
Ja, da gebe ich lieber
irgendwie 30
Respec Points nochmal zusätzlich aus,
um zu respecken, bevor ich mich da irgendwie rumquäle.
Und mit irgendeinem Mülllevel.
Außerdem macht Spellslinger
Level unglaublich Spaß.
Das ist glaube ich eines der spaßigsten
Level Builds, die man so machen kann in dem Spiel.
Also
auch Dings hier.
WD Nekro Dings.
Macht auch übelst Bock.
Zu leveln.
Nicht WD.
VD heißt es ja.
Volatile Dead.
Ja, ich finde Spellslinger
macht übelst Spaß zu leveln.
Was? Es verschenkt
im Chat Lasagne? What?
Moment, jetzt bin ich verwirrt. Chat.
Außerdem, warum geht es hier nicht weiter?
Du liest den ingame...
Nein, nein, ich liest den ingame Chat nicht. Der ingame Chat
ist meistens
Trolls die Trolle trollen.
Und ab und zu mal ein bisschen Toxic geflame.
Eigentlich,
eigentlich müsste ich den ingame Chat
ausblenden sogar.
Weil dort manchmal die ein oder anderen
Sachen etwas nicht ganz so
Twitch TOS konforme Sachen geschrieben werden.
Geht um
Lasagne. Ja, da gibt es nicht...
Das Game is free to play.
Du musst dich einloggen.
Musst ihm schreiben. Was wurscht ihr
das mit Lasagne?
Chat.
Vielleicht sollte ich mal specken
eine Runde. Äh, wo sind wir noch
stehen geblieben hier? Gehen wir mal hoch.
Tja, ich specke
mal, ich specke mal
zu dem...
Wo ist das? Zu dem Juwelsockel.
Das können wir garantiert
gleich gebrauchen für irgendwas.
Jetzt ist die Frage,
gehen wir erst zu den Chaos Damage
Nodes hoch?
Oder, wir gehen zu den Chaos
Dam... Alles was man killt,
kann dich nicht mehr killen. Ist doch ganz einfach.
Wobei, die hier sind auch nicht schlecht.
Egal.
Alterations sind die League
irgendwie ziemlich teuer.
Warum eigentlich?
Das stimmt.
Nook hebt das wirklich ab.
Wobei, PoE läuft wahrscheinlich
läuft, läuft fast überall.
Wahrscheinlich sogar auf Nintendo
DS. Das wär's noch.
PoE DS Port.
Eigentlich wär das mal, jetzt mal Leute,
ehrlich, das wär ein geiler DS
Port, oder?
PoE Mobile auf dem DS, wär doch echt nice.
Ich weiß, es kommt, es kommt
jetzt demnächst ja richtiges Mobile.
Also nicht auf dem
neueren DS.
Wird dann Cast & Crit...
Wird's.
Aber ich muss mir noch Gear kaufen.
Ich habe ein bisschen Reserve.
Aber mal gucken,
wie weit ich komm.
Ich hoffe, dass ich mit 2-3 Exhauls ein halbwegs
Budget Build hinkriege.
Dass ich nicht mal
einen ganzen Krempel da reinhauen muss.
Wo geht's denn lang hier?
Schon, ach nee.
Mein Atlas sieht traurig aus.
Den zeig ich dir nicht.
Der sieht übelst traurig aus.
So, Game.
Wo geht's denn jetzt lang?
Kann doch nicht sein. Ich renn hier nur in Sackgassen gerade.
Hier. Ah, excellent.
Die Map hat
extrem viele Magic Packs.
Au.
Ist ja gut.
So, wir...
Jetzt. Meine Güte.
Der will's aber wissen.
Ah.
Jetzt aber.
Haben wir da irgendwas dabei?
Müll, Müll.
Ah, ne.
Du bist gerade am überlegen, dir einen neuen PC zu holen?
Ja.
Also ich bin ja auch schon am überlegen,
die ganze Zeit,
seit Ende letzten Jahres,
mir einen neuen PC zu holen.
Aber es lohnt sich nicht
zu upgraden. Deswegen
habe ich mich drauf,
dass AMD
Ende des Jahres, oder nicht Ende des Jahres,
dass AMD jetzt demnächst, hoffentlich mal bald,
mit neuen CPUs vorbeikommt,
die Intel wirklich komplett im Regen stehen lassen
und dass Nvidia endlich mit einer neuen
Grafikkartengeneration um die Ecke kommt.
Dann kaufe ich mir auch wieder einen.
Weil aktuell lohnt sich's einfach nicht.
Mir juckt's. Ohne Scheiß, mir juckt's
in den Fingern, seit
letztes Jahr
die neuen Ryzen rausgekommen sind,
habe ich mir gedacht,
ich muss noch einen neuen PC kaufen.
Aber es lohnt sich halt 0
von einem 8700K.
Wenn's darum geht, kann man immer warten.
Man kann auch sinnlos sein, Geld ausgeben.
Es lohnt sich halt nicht.
Ich seh's nicht ein,
auch wenn man die Kohle hat,
ich seh's nicht ein, irgendwie 3000 Euro
oder so auszugeben für einen Rechner,
der 15% schneller ist,
als mein Alter.
Das ist doch...
doch Müll.
Gibt es bei einem Spiel immer
so Ligen für eine gewisse Zeit
oder wenn ein Spiel beginnt, Open End beides?
Es gibt alle drei Monaten ungefähr
eine neue League mit neuer Mechanik.
Also sprich, jede League ist
ein bisschen anders.
Diesmal kann man besonders gut craften.
Und es gibt aber auch,
wenn man nicht möchte, wenn man keine
Liga spielen will, kann man auch
Standard Open End spielen.
Standard Open End hat den
Vor- und Nachteil, du hast
keine Leak-Mechaniken, manche Leute
mögen das nicht.
Und du hast
High End Items, die sind ein bisschen
besser available.
Dafür musste da auch erstmal ein Currency kommen,
ein Standard.
Der Michael Fünfspilian ist am Start.
Moin, auch mal wieder am Start.
Pog.
Ears.
Pog like this.
Ah, wir sind 38.
Leute, wir sind 38.
Wir können upgraden.
Poggers, jetzt, jetzt geht's ab hier.
Jetzt wird das Bild
noch mehr OP.
Moment, wo ist hier mein...
Frenzy?
Zack.
Moment, was brauche ich in Frenzy?
Ah, Curse on Hit.
Curse on Hit, Faster Attacks.
Faster Attacks.
Curse on Hits.
Dis...
Wie schreibt man das? Despair.
Des...
Despair.
Ja.
Äh, Moment.
Wir müssen kurz das ganze mal ein bisschen
umwursten.
So.
Despair.
Hop, nein damit.
So, wer kriegt Multiple
Projectiles?
Solrent.
Wo haben wir Solrent drinne?
Solrent? Wait a minute.
Wait a minute.
Wie verteile ich denn das jetzt am besten?
Kannst du den Payspin
in den Chat kopieren?
Äh, ja.
Äh.
Moment.
Wie gesagt, ist nicht von mir. Habe ich mir auch noch abgeguckt.
Ah.
Habe ich noch, habe ich noch...
Was brauche ich denn noch? Ich brauche einen 4-Link, oder?
Brauche noch einen 4-Link.
Solrent Creator Multiple Projectiles.
Okay, also den Kram
hier habe ich fertig.
Wo soll denn überhaupt jetzt...
Ich bin jetzt gerade mal...
Wo kommt jetzt Increased Area Support nochmal dabei?
Ah.
Contagion. Okay, Contagion kommt dann hier rein.
Increased Area.
Äh, Increased
Area.
Increased Area Support.
So, und jetzt fehlt mir noch Solrent,
Spellslinger
und Multiple Projectiles, oder?
Genau.
So, wo kriege ich denn das?
Wo kriege ich denn das jetzt rein?
Da muss ich ja eigentlich Handschuhe...
Alter, habe ich irgendwelche Handschuhe, wo der Kram reinpasst?
Äh.
MonkaS.
Ich meine,
in der Aube passt das nicht. Nein.
Gloves. Ich brauche
Grün.
Grün, Blau, Blau, Blau.
Gucken wir mal, ob ich noch sowas habe. Wenn nicht, muss ich nur ein bisschen...
Ah.
41.
Vielleicht warte ich einfach bis 41.
Ich bin immer lang.
Aber ja, schnell.
Oder aber...
Den Crap, den will ich... Da will ich keine Currency für ausgeben.
Was kauf du,
Ethrit? Echt?
Zeig mal, ja. Trade.
Ja, der Ko...
Koal...
Asound kenne ich aus.
Das da?
Oh, das ist cool.
So, und das Ganze jetzt allerdings bitteschön noch mit...
Drei...
Ne. Drei Blau,
Drei Grün,
und vier Links.
Easy.
Ja, komm mal her. Whisper.
Ah. Lull.
Also dafür, da mache ich mir doch gar keinen Kopf.
Reiche mal
nächste. Oh, der nächste kostet schon 5.
Uh, okay. Also wenn der mir das für
einen verkauft, dann ist aber...
Das ist Debate-Angebot.
Der will triggern, dass die Leute ihm das
verkaufen dafür.
So.
Komm, ich gebe dafür auf 5 aus. Ist mir doch egal.
Ich habe genug. Juckt mich überhaupt nicht.
Ähm...
Stimmt. Color Sockets
sind einfach... Mal gucken, ob der jetzt... Wenn der mich
invidet, dann mache ich es. Ansonsten...
So.
Welcher war das jetzt?
Äh...
Den Typen habe ich überhaupt nicht angewispert.
Ah.
Ich bin auch beim Falschen. Den da habe ich
angewispert.
Hast recht. Lohnt sich wahrscheinlich echt nicht.
Aber ist doch wurscht. Geht's jetzt direkt
weiter. Ups.
Hideout.
Äh...
Wo sind wir? Stehen geblieben.
Was? Ein Chaos in
2000 Chromes?
Echt jetzt?
So viel? What the fuck?
Moment, warte mal.
Da musst du gerade mal kurz gucken.
Kann das sein hier?
Gar nicht mal.
Ja, genug. Ich habe ja auch noch genug.
Ah, wurscht. Passt.
So.
Äh...
Fire Resistance könnte man ein bisschen drauf machen.
Also machen wir den Kram. Zack.
Zack. Zack.
Zack.
So. Irgendwo machen wir nochmal ein bisschen Fire Resistance.
Wo können wir nochmal schnell Fire Resistance drauf machen?
Strength brauchen wir nicht.
Ja, irgendwo...
Irgendwo hier machen wir mal schnell mal Fire Resistance drauf.
Bisschen Fire Resistance
kann nichts schaden.
Nochmal schnell nochmal, dass uns nicht irgendwas
killt.
Billigste vom Billigen.
Dieser Crab Ring.
Und...
Da geht es weiter.
Stimmt. Ja, auf Level Requirement
habe ich nicht geguckt.
Habe ich ein bisschen Glück gehabt dabei.
So.
Jetzt sind wir noch ziemlich gut
equipped.
Alles fast max.
Moment, ist mein Portal...
Wo ist mein Portal hin?
Ach ne, ich habe gequittet, oder?
Was?
Moment.
Sagt bloß, mir fehlt jetzt Mana.
Nein! Moment, Moment.
Ich muss Dings backen. Ah!
Äh, Mana Reservation.
Mana Reservation gab es doch hier.
Habe ich nicht geskillt. Wo war Mana Reservation?
Ja.
Da muss ich hin.
Äh...
Okay, ein Level noch. Ein Level hat man so aus.
Aber dann
gibt es Ultra-Damage nach dem...
Wir sind ja hier fast durch.
Guck mal, wie schnell
die XP geht.
Oh, ich habe meinen Flamedash vergessen.
No. Ich habe meinen Flamedash
vergessen.
Na Michael, da bin ich ja
froh, dass du da bist.
Flame.
Okay.
Geht Enlighten mit Spellslinger?
Es geht nur...
Es gehen nur aktive Sachen mit Spellslinger.
Du kannst die aktiven Sachen mit einem Support-Gem supporten.
Aber du musst gucken,
dass
die Mana-Reservierung hinhaut.
Achso, ich?
Bei mir reicht die Mana-Reservierung nicht mehr.
Ich kriege jetzt ja schon nicht mal alles raus.
Das Problem ist, dass
je umso mehr Support-Gems du drin hast,
umso mehr Mana reserviert es.
Achso, mit Enlighten. Könnte sein, ja.
Aber die Kombi
ist jetzt echt top.
Wie gesagt, mir fehlt ja noch
ein Skill noch für ein Level.
Dann gibt es noch Mana-Reservierung.
Wait a minute.
Ist das genau die gleiche Map wie eben?
Wirkt so.
Habt ihr Curse und Hit gerade getriggert sehen?
Au.
Arnele.
Ja, das mit Enlighten könnte man echt machen.
Wobei ich keins mehr habe. Ich habe die alle gesellt.
Aber, guck mal.
Fürs Leveln hier.
Ich habe alle gesellt.
Ich habe Glück gehabt. Ich habe relativ viele
getroppt. Ich habe, glaube ich, drei
drei rote
Enlighten-Dinger getroppt.
Ich habe, ähm...
Ich habe getroppt. Ist eigentlich auch so eine dämliche, ähm...
Redewendung, die eigentlich überhaupt keinen Sinn ergibt.
Äh, und zwei
blaue.
Übelst lucky gewesen.
Also gleich am Anfang von der League, wovon ich dann
mein Nekro ausrüsten konnte.
So, jetzt please level up, dass ich
Mana-Reservation machen kann.
Also ganz, ganz ohne...
Ach, stimmt.
Stimmt, stimmt. Ja, ja, du hast recht.
Ja, ja, klar.
Ja, ja. Blaues
Enlighten. Genau.
So. Mana-Reservierung.
Haha!
Oh!
Hahaha! Null!
Hahaha! Aber es funktioniert!
Hahaha!
Foggers!
Aber ich kann kein Flamendash mehr einsetzen.
Was? Nicht so schlimm ist, ich bräuchte einfach
noch ein bisschen Mana. Ich craft, ich craft.
Ich crafte mir einfach schnell mal Mana drauf.
Ey, ich hab keine...
Ich hab keine Portal-Scrolls.
Ich brauch Portal-Scroll,
please.
Ach, kommt schon, im nächsten.
Nehm einfach irgendwo
nen Support-Gem raus. Ich könnte auch ein bisschen Mana
drauf craften, irgendwo.
Wir machen...
Increased Area machen wir raus.
Increased Area, wo hab ich
denn das? Ja.
Increased Area machen wir mal raus, das ist nicht so wild.
Mana-Craft bringt
nix, ist Prozent.
Ähm...
Warte mal, doch, das müsste...
Das müsste, glaube ich, was
bringen. Ich glaube nicht, dass es 100%
Reservierungen sind, aber wahrscheinlich ist das
irgendeine Abrund-Geschichte oder so.
Sehen wir ja gleich.
Ach, ne. Oder der nächste Skill
reduziert vielleicht noch mehr. Warte mal.
Let's gucken. Passives.
Ah, guck mal, der nächste
macht 8%. Ja, dann ist klar.
Ja, dann ist easy.
Wenn der nächste nochmal 8% macht,
dann hab ich überhaupt kein Problem.
Dann ist easy as fuck.
Hätte ich gleich
immer am Anfang skillen sollen. Ich hab nicht drauf geachtet,
dass es da unten die Skill-Notes gibt.
Und dass man die braucht.
Alter, die Map!
Die jebaitet mich ja hart gerade.
Überall, wo ich denke,
dass es weitergeht, geht nicht weiter.
Ähm...
Die hab ich bei Porkbun gekauft, Michael,
in die Domains.
Allerdings hat Porkbun
keine DNS-
API. Deswegen haben die
mich ja gesperrt, weil ich versucht
hab, ihre Webseite zu
äh...
skripten.
Das hat denen nicht gepasst.
Ähm...
Aber die sind halt echt billig.
Na, Porkbun. Und zum hosten,
ich hoste nix extern.
Wenn ich mal
was brauche, mach ich mir ne DigitalOcean4M.
Alter, die Map jebaitet
krass. Mach ich mir ne DigitalOcean4M
auf die Schnelle.
Wobei ich ihn jetzt eher zu
HetznerCloud tendiere sogar.
Also das nächste Mal,
wenn ich OpenStreetViewMaps
preprocessen muss, kaufe ich mir ne HetznerCloud4M.
Und ja, wenn ich
was hosten würde, würde ich es wahrscheinlich auch
HetznerCloud kaufen.
Kommt halt drauf an, was du...
Der Raum ist sehr sinnvoll.
Sag mal.
Sag bloß da...
Also die Map ist wirklich gerade der Wahnsinn.
Also falsche hätte man nicht laufen können.
Überall immer Sackgasse.
Man muss schon sagen, Spellslinger-Level
macht echt mega Bock.
Moment, hier kann es nicht lang gehen. Das hätte ich von der anderen
Seite gesehen.
So, jetzt please, lass mich mal den Weg finden.
Wann hast du das letzte Mal Diablo 3
gespielt?
Vor zwei Jahren oder so.
Ich kann mir aber nicht
vorstellen, dass sich da so grundlegend
was getan hat, oder?
Hat sich? Weiß nicht. Kannst du dir nicht vorstellen.
Moin, DoppelFelix98.
Mein Rifts
und das ganze Gedöns mit Self-Found
kenne ich ja schon.
Ololololo.
Den Boss habe ich am Anfang nie gecheckt.
Dabei muss man einfach nur hinter
der rumlaufen und es passiert einem nichts.
Oh, okay. Also.
Außer das.
Jetzt ist er mal gut.
Er ist groß gelabert, ne? Und dann
fast verreckt.
Grundlegend hat sich nichts geändert.
Also, wie gesagt, die Rift-Geschichte
habe ich in Diablo 3 noch mitgekriegt. Dass es jetzt
Self-Found only ist, habe ich auch noch mitgekriegt.
Ähm.
Ja.
Das war es im Großen und Ganzen.
Und die Rifts haben mir überhaupt nicht gefallen.
Ja, ich verstehe, dass Rifts und Maps
nicht so
großartig unterschiedlich sind. Ich meine, Rift hat
verschiedene Ebenen. Das ist ein bisschen wie Delph,
so in die Richtung, irgendwie die
Rift-Geschichte. Aber was mir in Rifts überhaupt nicht
gefallen hat, dass es alles so hässliche,
extrem bunte Höhlen
waren, irgendwie.
Da war vom normalen Game
überhaupt nichts da, mehr übrig.
Außerdem hat mir Diablo 3 von Anfang an nicht gut gefallen.
Ich brauch,
by the way, ich bräuchte mal, ich bräuchte mal
ne,
ne Portal-Scroll.
Ich bräuchte mal ein bisschen Portal-Scrolls.
Oder besser gesagt,
ich müsste die mal aufnehmen.
By the way, warum renne ich eigentlich an den
Portal-Scrolls?
Ich bin da jetzt vorbei.
Ich bin stehen geblieben.
Ja, weil ich irgendwie nach
Portal-Scrolls geguckt hab.
Voll bescheuert.
Get Shracked.
Ich brauch ein Portal.
Diese Bosse hier, ne,
die sind recycelt as fuck.
Die kommen hier an den Start,
die kommen später, der kommt,
ich glaub, der kommt sogar viermal, der Dude hier.
Der kommt in der Map dann später nochmal
Also Boss-Recycling vom Feinsten,
was sie hier abgeliefert haben.
Mach Auge.
Chat macht Auge.
Weil der verrecke ich immer.
Weil der nicht weiß, wo ich mich hinstellen muss.
Könnte, könnte mal Please
eine
Portal-Scroll
droppen?
Oder ist das grad nicht im RNG
vorhanden?
Hier doch zum Waypoint, ja.
Kann ich auch machen, aber trotzdem.
Warum gibt's keine Portal-Scrolls?
Der ganze Dungeon hatte keine Portal-Scrolls.
Und ich drück immer schon Alt zwischendurch,
falls mein Loot-Filter spackt oder so.
Es gibt nix.
Nee.
Ich hab den normalen Strict-Filter,
das ist da eigentlich drinnen.
Wartet mal.
Ich hätte gern noch
ein Level.
Irgendwas.
Mir vollkommen egal.
Oh, okay.
If.
Level. Einfach nur ein Level.
Wir haben ja kaum was.
Oh nee, jetzt lauf ich auch noch raus.
Nee.
Oder auch nicht, oder was?
MonkaS.
Wenn du länger als echt
jetzt
klaustest, dann nee.
Nee.
Ich hab den Waypoint, ich hab mit Piety geredet.
Darf ich den nochmal machen, oder?
Oh nee, ich komm auch nicht mehr zurück.
Echt?
Okay, dann mach ich das jetzt.
Das ist okay.
Aber ich brauch nicht länger als 10 Minuten.
Guck mal.
Ich hab jetzt Level up.
Okay, fast.
Jetzt. Jetzt hab ich Level up.
Meine Güte.
Jetzt hab ich Level up.
Level up. Level up.
Jetzt porten wir zurück.
By the way, Scrolls sind out.
Äh.
Weil.
Kann ich den Kram wieder aktivieren.
Mal die Reservierung
crappen.
Und.
Increased Area wieder rein machen.
Und ich hab ganze 37 Mana.
Poggers.
Und jetzt ist es, wenn wir den Boss bashen.
Auf Laber nicht so viel.
Lass ich killen.
Big Brain Boss, der gleich stirbt.
Oh nee. Ach, das ist dieser.
Ja, ja.
Jetzt ja gut.
So, jetzt aber.
Ich mach zu viel Damage.
Die Mechanics wollen nicht mitmachen.
Ah, jetzt haben wir's.
Der war schon fast down.
Aber die Mechanics von dem Fight haben gesagt.
Nope, du musst jetzt.
Weil ich hab immer noch keine Portal-Scroll.
Aber wenn man stirbt, passiert ja nichts.
Also wenn man stirbt, wird er direkt wieder gespawnt.
Ja, ja.
Damit Tentacle monstert wieder.
So, jetzt aber.
Get Shracked.
Es fährt erst mal im Fahrstuhl runter.
So, please sterben.
Jetzt.
Exzellent.
Alles zählen gleich.
Wobei, warum?
Brauch nix, ich hab genug.
So.
Akt 4 fertig.
Oder Akt 5?
Moment, welcher Akt ist das?
4?
4, ne?
4 war das jetzt.
Ah, die.
Irgendwann.
Ich kann nicht weiter als 3 zählen.
Jetzt muss ich erst mal noch ein paar
Skills und Gedöns abholen.
Von dem krieg ich noch ein Skillbook.
Ja.
Dem muss ich noch ein Skillbook abholen.
Hier oben krieg ich jetzt glaub ich noch irgendwelche
Gems, die ich nicht brauche.
Ach, guck mal.
Increased Area angekriegt.
Alles nett.
Kann ich aber zu einem Fall eh kaufen.
So, jetzt müssen wir noch den Berg hoch und dann ist der Akt vorbei.
Und Chat, ich sag euch,
es ist viel später geworden, als ich eigentlich vorhatte.
Guck mal hier.
Das ist der...
Clearspeed ist so krass in der Kampagne.
Einfach grad auslaufen, casten und alles stirbt.
Ach, man muss
irgendwo hin drücken, okay.
Für die Speedruns.
Ja, Grundstein ist gelegt, ne?
Das Speedrun-Meta-Bild hab ich
ja schon mal drauf hier.
Muss noch ein bisschen besser werden, um zu erkennen,
wo es auf den Karten lang geht, ey.
Ich hab ja, ehrlich gesagt,
keine großartige Speedrun-Ambition.
Aber ich würde gerne,
auch für zukünftige Leaks und alles,
also Leagas,
nicht Leaks,
einfach die Kampagne schnell durchkriegen.
Das hier ist ja auch ein super Starter-Bild,
letztendlich.
Da waren TPs.
Die neuen Exhauls, Alter.
Jetzt zu spät.
Okay, erst
TP-Scroll. Wo ist meine TP-Scroll?
TP-Scroll.
Oh, nice.
Ah!
Excellent.
Habt ihr's gesehen?
Ich hab eine Portal-Scroll.
By the way, das Game war
am Anfang fertig, also als
es neu war, ging das
Game nur
bis zu dem
Fight im Lunaris-Tempel
gegen Piety. Danach war Schluss.
Also, das ist in der Beta.
Danach kam irgendwann Dominus.
Das ist dieser Typ auf dem Dach,
der sich dann in so einen Dämon verwandelt hat
und dann war fertig. Die ganzen Acts
kamen erst später.
Letzte Season um die 25
Exhauls auf einem Charverbraten. Irgendwie
null Ambition für die Season gehabt. Ja, ich hab letzte
Season nicht gespielt.
Hab ja auch keinen Bock.
Ähm...
Ich find aber eigentlich grade, dass die Motivation
dadurch, dass sich das resettet,
zumindest hilft das bei mir.
Aber bei, äh...
25 Exhauls
auf der hohen Kante bin ich
grad noch nicht.
Ich hab grad, glaub nur 500 Ruhe.
Da muss ich noch ein bisschen farmen.
Und bisschen Zeug verkaufen.
Ähm... Ja, ich find die...
Ich bin auch kein Fan von Harvest.
Kräfte auch nicht gerne.
Aber...
Warum mir persönlich Harvest
trotzdem gefällt ist,
dass so extrem krasses Gear,
also irgendwie, äh...
Chests mit, äh...
Exploding-Dings, wie heißt's?
Ähm...
Äh... Dealing...
Also, ja, wenn die Gegner explodieren und dann irgendwie
gewisse Prozentzahl Physical Damage
machen, gepaart mit
Reflect Immunity
und sowas, das waren halt mega
krasse Dinger. Und die sind jetzt
relativ häufig, das heißt, wenn man's
so macht, äh...
Wie wir
im Endeffekt, wenn man Harvest nicht mag,
verkauft man einfach seine Seeds,
weil die Seeds bringen fette Kohle,
und kauft
sich die Sachen, die andere gecraftet haben.
Ich mag Harvest
auch nicht. Aber es sorgt
dafür, dass so richtig übertrieben
geile Items mehr vorhanden sind.
Das find ich gut.
Und wenn man selbst lieber
hier Kreisel grindet und farmt,
anstatt
zu craften, kann man die sich auch
kaufen, indem man Seeds verkauft, also
man macht massig Kohle mit Seeds
verkaufen.
Man kann
aktuell, äh...
Item Level
plus Seeds verkaufen für
mindestens 0,3
C
pro Seed.
Also ich hab, ich hab heute Morgen
über, das muss man leider, muss man
leider über den Discord machen, weil das die offizielle
Trading-Seite nicht unterstützt,
äh, Bulk-Verkauf
von Seeds. Ich hab heute Morgen ungefähr
1500,
1500, what the fuck?
Ja, 1500, äh...
Seeds verkauft, das war ungefähr
die Hälfte von dem, was ich hab,
mal 0,3, und das war schon echt
billig. Man hätte da durchaus
0,35 oder so rausholen können.
Das waren dann ungefähr
450 Chaos, das sind
ich...
3,66
Holz, einfach für ein bisschen Seeds-Gefarme.
Und jetzt hab ich nochmal so viel
ungefähr 81 plus Seeds, die versuch ich
für 0,4 zu verkaufen.
Äh, Delirium hab ich nicht gespielt.
Hab ich aber auch gelesen,
dass
das wohl ziemlicher Abfuck für einige war.
Ja, also ich kann nicht
verstehen, dass das ziemlicher Abfuck für einige
war, Delirium. Also ich kenn ja die
Delirium Mechanic, die
gibt's ja jetzt auch auf den normalen Maps.
Was ist denn das hier eigentlich?
Irgendwelche Pets von Leuten?
Ja.
Alter, ich seh so richtig low aus,
Alter, guck mal.
Ich seh
so richtig low aus.
Könnt ihr wenigstens mal Microtransactions drauf machen,
äh?
Diese hässliche Mütze.
Guck's euch mal an, das sieht so schlecht aus.
So ein Schlafanzug, Hemd und so eine Mütze auf, Alter.
Naja, ähm...
Also, was passiert mit Chars,
wenn die Season endet? Dann werden
die Charaktere nach Standard
kopiert. Du kannst sie weiterspielen.
Allerdings natürlich nicht in der nächsten Season.
Weil nächste Season...
Nächste Season ist halt...
Oh!
Wie hab ich das geschafft,
dass ich nur noch einen übrig hab?
Genau einen, das müssen wir erstmal schaffen.
Das ist auch sowas, was ich nicht ganz
verstehe, ist...
Warum haben die hier
keine Suche im Shop ingame?
Wenn ich jetzt nach Pets suchen will
und nach den Gartenzwergen,
dann kann ich hier gar nicht suchen richtig.
Okay.
Wenigstens irgendwas, irgendwas ausrüsten.
Ja, hab ich nix für.
In use.
Ah. Aha.
Oh ne.
Ah, Moment.
Ich hab's schon gekippt.
Was?
Ach so, weil's ein Weapon ist. Das ist der Effekt,
den man nur mag. Das macht's auch nicht
besser, oder?
Okay, das sieht jetzt sogar ganz gut aus.
Da passt jetzt aber das Engelsschild
nicht wirklich zu, ne?
So, erst mal ein bisschen Microtransactions
ausrüsten, ja?
Also,
ohne geht ja nicht.
So. Gut.
Jetzt machen wir wenigstens ein bisschen was her, optisch.
Unten Filter
Microtransactions.
Bin ich blind?
Ach, da!
What the fuck?
Das ist mir...
Ach, hier ist das gar nicht.
Ah.
Okay, Pets.
Ach so, ja. Dwarf?
Wie heißen die Dinger denn?
Ich fand die übelst nice.
Aber ich kann's mir eh nicht kaufen, weil ich hab nur noch einen Punkt.
Ach ja, paar Flügel.
Paar Flügel. Flügel brauchen wir auch noch.
Flügel brauchen wir auch noch.
Oder Ohma. Oh.
Ey, das...
Okay, warum hat das Ding
Waffen auf dem Rücken, die ich überhaupt nicht habe?
Das gefällt mir nicht. Das suckt.
Dann lieber...
Dann lieber Flügel dabei.
Das ist ne Kombi, ha?
Lol.
Das ist ne scheiß Kombi.
Vorne wird gebrannt.
Und der Rest leuchtet.
Okay, was gibt's für Essence Train?
Oh.
Mind Blown.
Excellent.
Na gut. Okay, Leute. Es reicht für heut.
Genug.
Was haben wir denn hier?
Blade.
Vier Stunden.
Naja, Hälfte vom Game und gefährst durch, ha?
Hälfte vom Game durch.
Na, acht Stunden Kampagne, lol.
Speedrun, please.
Oder wo sind wir nun ungefähr?
Ja, Hälfte kommt hin, oder?
Die Akte, die jetzt kommen...
Also, außer dem Akt.
Der Akt dauert jetzt noch ein bisschen.
Aber die ganzen...
Also, Akt 6, 7, 8, 9, 10...
Das ist ja teilweise...
...mehr oder weniger geradliniges Durchgerenne.
Was? Slash Death 5 oder so?
Ne.
Ja, diese League ist krass.
Also...
...mit Seeds verkaufen...
...man kann übelst Kohle machen.
Ich hab das überhaupt nicht optimiert betrieben.
Jetzt...
Also, ich hab mir da nie Gedanken drüber gemacht.
Und hab das alles gehortet, ja? Richtig dumm.
Ähm...
Aber mit dem...
Also, gerade mit Seeds farmen...
...kannst du übelst Kohle machen, gerade.
Du hast ja teilweise Seeds, die sind bis zu 15, 20 Chaos wert.
Find das übelst nice.
Ja, und ansonsten...
Also, ich hab letztens ein Video gesehen...
...von einem, der hat...
...eine Auswertung gefahren mit...
...Mit Drops über, glaub...
...5, 6 oder irgendwie einen Tag farmen...
...und der ist auf, glaub ich...
...900 Chaos die Stunde gekommen.
Das ist halt echt heftig.
So viel, wenn du dir überlegst...
...das ist komplett High-End Content...
...und auch ein ordentliches High-End...
...Equip...
...und Build braucht, dass du das...
...machen kannst.
Das sind ja ungefähr dann...
...das...
...900 Chaos sind...
...dann haben wir 130.
Okay, runden wir mal auf, 7 Exhauls die Stunde...
...das ist schon ordentlich...
...aber wenn du dir vorstellst, dass dann halt auch...
...manchmal richtig krasse Sachen droppen und...
...vielleicht...
...steht man doch auf das Gecrafte...
...man kann da schon ordentlich...
...Currency machen...
...wenn man das optimiert betreibt.
Mein Scheiß, Ultra High-End.
Ohne der 41, ja.
Also mein Main geht...
...sogar, mein Main ist gar nicht so schlecht...
...hier, der hier.
Wobei, ich müsste mal richtig...
...ohne Bosse zu machen, weil...
...bei denen verrecke ich manchmal.
Also der ist bei weitem nicht perfekt, ja.
Also ich brauche auf jeden Fall noch...
...unbedingt mehr...
...einen besseren Helm, weil der sackt...
...ziemlich.
Ich brauche einen Helm, der Mana-Reservierungen macht...
...und...
...noch ein bisschen mehr Life gibt.
Die Chest ist ganz nice.
Ah, und ansonsten...
...hab sogar ein Portal drin.
Die Boots...
...sind auch nicht so dolle.
Ähm...
...der Staff ist ganz okay.
Also das ist alles kein krasses...
...High-End Zeug, ne.
Die Chest ist aber ganz nice.
Die Chest...
...da bezahlst du auch ganz gut was für.
Wobei, ist ziemlich...
...gedroppt im Preis.
Nicht getroppt.
Na gut.
Leute, ich geh jetzt ins Bett pennen.
Morgen früh aufwachen, streamen.
Ich hoffe, euch hat's gefallen.
Bis dann.
Wir sehen uns. Macht's gut. See you.